there we go
okay good evening everybody and welcome
to tonight's virtual meeting of
stratford-union district council's
planning committee my name is councillor
peter richards
and you may be able to hear my son in
the background um i'm tonight's
chairman for this meeting um a bit of
housekeeping
if i may first of all please the meeting
is being streamed live and recorded for
publication
on the council's website and youtube
members you have been given
the council's etiquette for virtual
meetings in advance of tonight's meeting
however just to reiterate a few of the
key points
please make sure your device is charged
or is charging
uh please mute your microphones when you
are not speaking speaking and of course
unmute them when you are speaking
when you wish to speak if you could
indicate in the chat bar for me please
and i will call you at an appropriate
time
um if for any reason you encounter any
i.t
issues there are phone numbers in the
meeting chat now for you to call
you will have been deemed to have left
the meeting at the point you drop out
please make every endeavor to get back
in
uh if you can't get back in and say
you'll have been deemed to have left and
we will continue business provided we
are
still correct um just to confirm uh four
members of the public and our viewers uh
we have prized this meeting and in front
of our
uh legal officer confirmed that members
can see and hear everything they have
read all the documentation including
the update sheet we have a series of
uh officers online with us as well
tonight and from committee services we
have
liz jaworska from our legal services our
solicitor is
ross chambers and in no particular order
our planners are
louise coleman sarah mcpherson erin
weatherston
and ryan o'keefe and our planning
manager is tracy humphries
tracy i believe you have a statement
you'd like to make yes
thank you chairman and good evening
members and members of the public
um i'm tracy hopfries and my role in
tonight's meeting as your planning
manager is to provide impartial advice
and to assist members in their
decision-making thank you
marvelous thank you very much um for our
public speakers or anyone that has
registered to speak
um i will run through uh what is
expected uh at that point or
at a point uh where you're about to
speak but please if you would follow
along
your application with your sound like
you're in
sorry for that i don't know what
happened there uh if you could please
follow on with your handsets uh rather
than the live stream there is a minor
delay of about 10 seconds so
um uh when you're cool to speak it will
be best to be heard through the the
headset um you'll need to press start
and six to unmute yourself at an
appropriate time but i'll remind you to
do that
at that time okay let's move on to our
agenda we do have a very thick agenda so
we'll try and get through this as
quickly as we can apologies first of all
please liz
thank you chairman we have apologies
from councillors edin and hensha serafin
this evening
marvelous thank you very much um and any
discloses of
interest i will start us off on that um
application forgive me i have
written it down on the wrong page
uh it is application number 2001 398 ful
that is filled adjacent to glennhurst
farm in clavidon i am the ward member
although i
come with a completely open mind and i
will remain part of the committee
during its deliberations debate and
decision could you please indicate in
the chat members if you have any
disclosures of interest
councillor fleming first please
uh yes cheer um item six on the agenda
i'm fairly certain it is
gonna bear with me for a second your
page is flipped over yeah item six
fifteen bernal
close um i am board member for that and
i'll be speaking
uh in on that particular item
so i will stand stand down from debate
and vote on that one
um and also uh number 100 high street
bidford on haven
um although i'm not ward member for that
one
i uh i was part of the paris council
that raised the objection that you'll
hear later as well on that one so
i'm declaring the fact that i did that
as well
okay just to confirm does that mean you
won't be taking part in the final
item as well um under advice i've said i
should
you know i shouldn't really take part in
that debate understood thank you very
much for that uh counselor dixon next
please
uh thank you chairman yes no personal
interest but
as the ward member for agenda item five
application twenty slash zero one eight
six
four uh twelve belfield tamithin arden
as the ward member i will be speaking
against that application
marvelous thank you very much um i see
no one else indicated in the chat so i
will assume we have no further
disclosures of interest
minutes uh everyone is everyone happy
for me to sign
the minutes quick show of hands please i
can see lots of thumbs up
yep that's unanimous marvelous i'll do
that next time we're in
okay our first application for the
evening then is application
reference 201132
out that has land off long martin road
on welford on
avon our presentation officer is louise
coleman louise
whenever you're ready over to you
thank you chair right
can everybody see my screen
hello certainly can yeah okay um
right uh just scrolling down
sorry hello
hi uh apologies
louise just both the gentleman that's
just joined us if you could press star
on six to mute your keypad and we'll
call you in
once we've had our presentations thank
you louise sorry back to you
yes sorry i'm just trying to share my
screen
um just having difficulty i can't
seem to scroll down um
ah there we go sorry there we are it's
okay
okay apologies for that right um the
application site is identified by the
black dot on the map
and is located in the open countryside
approximately 1.6 kilometers
south of welford and avon and backed
550 meters north of the edge of long
marston
the site is currently vacant and forms
part of a wider horticultural use
uh former use of uh
sorry known as rainbow nurseries the
site also
lies within the veil of asian control
zone to the north of the application
site here is a residential
gypsy site for 14 families to the south
is a substantial range of commercial
buildings used for the most part
as a self-store facility to the north
west is a skip and waste transfer
business um which also is located within
rainbow nursery holding
for former holding a residential
property to the
uh northwest sorry north east and
northwest and then to the east is uh
some additional uh dwellings
um as part of uh the eastern
uh sorry as part of the application um
site um planning commission
um what has been uh previously granted
uh for the direction of six gypsy
pictures in within this area
approximately here um so it does form
part of the red line site
um it was allowed on appeal in 2016
and a recent lawful development
certificate has determined that this is
not extant
the application is for an outline
permission
for b1 and b1a which is the
office uses which are now classified as
class e
uh b2 general industrial use and b8
uh storage and distribution uses all
with
matters relating to access landscaping
layout and scale all being reserved
the indicative layout shows a range of
21 units ranging from a size of about
111 square meters to
455 square meters um
access to the site is currently obtained
from the long marston road
um at the base of romney hill and is
about 50 sorry 80 meters from the
junction
with the d4 540
the uh access is an improved former
field access which means it measures six
meters in width in 10 meters
uh wide radii turnouts the access is
separate to that which
serves the gypsy sites and the waste
transfer business which is located 60
meters north
turning now to photographs of the site
this is the existing access into the
site as you can see the site's overgrown
and covered with shrub and self-seeded
trees
the western boundary is shown in the
foreground
this is a view towards a southern
boundary which abuts the
reed self storage unit
this is a view of the eastern boundary
with a view along longmarston road
this is a view of the northern
visibility splay towards
rumner hill this is the existing
14-pitch gypsy site
and this is the access to the commercial
premises which is the waste transfer
business there are no updates to report
and the recommendation chair is to
refuse the application
on the two grounds as specified in the
committee report
louise thank you very much for that uh
we will move straight to our first
speaker tonight who is councillor simon
carter from uh welfare ivan parish
council chairman in fact
uh council carter are you there you may
need to press star and six to unmute
your keypad
um oh i can hear you so no need to amuse
me yes i'm on an ordinary landline
actually so
i'm not sure i can deal with stars and
sixes and things
no problem at all so okay the good news
is we've got you you have three minutes
whenever you're
we have a slide i think uh yeah that's
been produced by yourself on screen now
so whenever you're already got three
minutes you'll have a 30 second warning
and then if we could stay on for
questions afterwards that'd be great
whenever you're ready
yeah okay thank you very much indeed uh
good evening councillors
so let's be clear this is not a
greenfield site and nor did louise or
robert
uh weeks think so in 2014 with
application 1402
02954 full
when this site was determined it was it
was deemed to be brownfield land
louise wrote at the time on page 14 of
the committee report
this is an effective use of brownfield
land
so i'll say it again this isn't a
greenfield site and therefore this
cannot be a reason for refusal
the whole rainbow nursery site is 27
acres in four parts
there are different commercial
activities taking place immediately to
the south and to the north as louise has
explained
the reeds storage area is a massive
complex and
it also has a vehicle repair and paint
shop amongst other things going on there
again on the rainbow nursery site to the
north there's an hdv workshop
and storage area a skip hire company and
a waste transfer station
the latter commercial activities were
consented to
in 2017 and 2018 on so-called greenfield
land
the words used by sdc at the time were
this is previously
developed land the existing gypsy sites
of 14 pitches were agreed
at appeal as stated so it sort of
suggests the site is sustainable
the llfa objection is strange because it
received received something like three
and a half months late
we'd even ask if it was legitimate
however even if it is
this area has no history of flooding and
more importantly this issue could easily
be sorted out with reserve matters
all conditioned now again
this is an outline application so the
subs issue that's been raised can all
could also be sorted out by way of
condition
roadways are a common position for suds
units these days as per
other developments in welford so there
is plenty of space
buses do pass the site entrance and so a
new bus stop could be conditioned as
part of a section 106 agreement
the application for rural employment
which is especially important
given that all existing employment sites
in welfare have been subsumed for
housing
and very important because there are in
excess of three and a half thousand
houses planned for the long master lower
quentin area
so much employment so as much employment
as possible is needed
in addition this application supports
the emerging sdc
updated site allocation plan i.e for
royal employment
which is further developed than the in
policy terms than the gypsy and traveler
sdcs
fpd so should carry more weight we think
actually the officers have been a little
underhand in recommending refusal to you
tonight
for a particularly good policy driven
application for this site
which i'm sure if refused would be one
on appeal
we know the applicant has always been
already been approached about more gypsy
sites before this application has even
been determined
we also know that the applicant does not
want more gypsy sites on this side
so he won't be bringing it forward for
that purpose
so please support this application
tonight thank you very much
council carter thank you very much for
that members uh do we have any
questions please councillor parry first
of all
uh thank you chairman and a good evening
councillor
um i just wondered whether you could
possibly clarify
for me in the office's report
whilst it does say it refers to it as
greenfield
horticultural use at present he does
make reference to it being in the open
countryside
um which brings me on to the
to um the criteria that you have in the
welford neighborhood
plan which which does not support
development in the open countryside i
wonder whether you could just give some
clarification on that
from your adopted neighborhood plan
thank you
yes so we do support development in open
countryside but we do have some
specific policies um in you know when we
do support it so
um you can develop an open countryside
if it's for ordinary residential use
then it would be
um you know properties of specific um
you know interest or innovation but
rural employment is an important factor
that we don't
that we need more of we've lost a lot of
royal employment
and um you know since our plan was
actually created so actually putting
something back i think at this stage
especially on this site is actually very
appropriate
hello okay thanks sorry i'd muted myself
it took me too long to unmute
sorry about that um thank you for that
members do we have any other questions
for councillor carter
if you if you could please indicate in
the chat if you do
i don't see much movement so cast i
think that's it so thank you very much
for your contribution
you're probably best off watching uh the
live stream from now on
um shall i
yeah if you would that'd be great thank
you okay thanks for watching thank you
very much thank you
bye bye okay we'll move then to our next
speaker who is mr darren cade the
architect
um for the application mr k can you hear
me you may need to press start
i can hear you mr chairman perfect we
can hear you as well welcome good
evening
um so similar to our previous speaker
you have three minutes uh we'll give you
a 30 second warning and if you could
stay on for questions afterwards that'd
be great
otherwise as soon as you're ready feel
free to start
uh thank you mr chairman and uh good
evening councillors
uh the current planning application is
for an outline approval
to establish a principle of industrial
and commercial development on the
application
site and to assist with the application
a number of specialist detailed reports
have also been submitted
these reports include the following a
transport assessment
a noise assessment a flood risk
assessment
additional information which may be
required could further be dealt with by
way of further conditions
the site itself had a previous
commercial use for horticulture
which included both greenhouses and
polytunnels
previously on the site and therefore
should be determined as a brownfield
site
and as such defined would determine the
site to be suitable for redevelopment
it is both the applicants and agents
opinion
that the site should therefore not be
considered as being in
open countryside a site layout plan
has been produced and submitted with the
application to purely demonstrate
that the site is suitable for industrial
use and accordingly
the layout plan has buildings access
roadways
parking and cycle parking provisions all
provided
rather than a blank site minus a layout
there have been no objections from
highways and the paris council
are also supporting the application
the site has been assessed by the
council as being an open countryside
however it should be noted that it had
previous commercial use
and also sits between two existing sites
both of which have had
existing established use for industrial
and commercial use
there are numerous sites within the
stratfor district council's area
which currently have approval for new
housing
mostly on sites that had not been built
on previously
yet without more sites for commerce and
industry
residential sites cannot be sustained
without employment
we would therefore respectfully ask the
committee to grant the application for
the outline approval
for the proposed development thank you
very much
mr cave thank you very much for that
members do you have any questions for
uh mr cave please indicate in the chat
if you do
i will ask a question while i wait for
you to do that uh mr cave
you talked about the land previously
being in commercial use can you tell me
when
uh the last time it was in commercial
use
please uh i believe
before 2010 when it was uh a
horticultural site it was obviously
known as
rainbows nurseries and this is
what we're referring to okay
lovely thank you very much um no one
else has any questions for you so
um thank you very much for your
contribution this evening again you're
probably best served to continue to
watch the live stream
uh so you can hang up your handset as
and when you're ready but thank you for
your contribution
okay thank you very much for your
services cheers thank you
okay so let's move to our final speaker
of uh this application
who is councillor pertigalla councilman
welcome
thank you um i think you know the drill
five minutes
30 second warning uh you can use as much
or as little time as you like
of that five minutes um and stay on for
questions whenever you're already do
feel free to start
okay good evening committee members i'm
here in support of the parish council
in their representations tonight as you
already heard the site is contained
without
within a much bigger site or 27 acres
which currently comprises 14 caravan
peaches
waste transfer system and i understand
there is a
hiv repair workshop a skip higher
business and therefore can be
characterized
also as an employment side and indeed i
understand there was an established
agricultural business
previously idea sent to the side there
is a larger self-storage business with
several warehouses
so this locality represents a rural
semi-industrial site and therefore we
can contribute to rural jobs
in a world where local employment sites
such as the long marston airfield
have been or are in the process of being
mainly transformed into housing sites
there is supporting the mppf for
businesses in rural areas
and the council emerging site allocation
plan also supports rural employment
sites
this site is considered as greenfield by
the planning team and i believe this
refers to the fact that originally the
site contained the horticultural or
agricultural business
but we've seen that there are other
types of uh businesses now operating for
the site
and in the surrounding locality so this
should not be a ground for refusal
there are some inconsistencies with the
characterization of the location of the
site
in its past planning history on page 12
of the current committee report
the officer says that the site is
located in open countryside therefore
unsustainable
but in a previous application 14
four 02954 ful which was for six caravan
peaches which the council wanted to
grant but was refused by the committee
and then allowed an appeal on page 17
under the sustainability section it is
stated and i quote
i consider that while this site is
outside a settlement
in a countryside location it is situated
next to a cluster of commercial
industrial residential
and an existing gypsy site and therefore
is not in an isolated open countryside
location end of court so
the same site can be considered
unsustainable as a commercial site
but also sustainable for residential
sites so which is confusing so which is
it
the other point for the refusal is the
objection by the
llfa because not enough information had
been provided regarding how the
development deals with any surface water
enough
and notwithstanding that the site is in
floods on one
as the parish council has suggested this
is an outline application
so any thoughts can be detailed as a
condition in the development
the objection came in quite late on the
17th of december and i understand
understand from the applicant that they
were given until the 6th of january to
respond
with drainage plans to the lfa
so this was very close to the christmas
or holiday period which reduced the
amount of clear working days
and the district was put in tier 3 and
then
from the 31st of december in tier 4 with
a clear message to stay at
home so i believe the more time could
have been given to the applicant so that
any consultant or engineer would have
been able to visit the site
and produce any plan to respond to the
lfa objection so um in conclusion i hope
therefore that you would grant
permission with any appropriate
conditions
such as the control zone travel plan
condition which i do agree with
um or a condition for sads and and so
forth
thank you casa persona thank you very
much for that we do have questions for
you if i could start with councillor
parry please
thank you good evening manuela and hope
you're well
um i just wonder whether you i've got
two
questions if i may um can you advise
does the site does this is this site
included for employment use
in the welfare development neighborhood
development plan
um and my second question
is do you know why having gone to
extreme lengths the applicant
no longer wishes to use the site as a
gypsy
and traveller site i can remember the
application very well
probably about sort of six years ago on
committee um when it went to appeal
so um i know obviously as a lot of
effort
went into the original application
for the land to be converted to uh gypsy
and traveller sites i'd like to know
if you have any information on that and
if the
and if not well and has the site does
the site
has it actually been earmarked in the
development plan
welfare development plan for light
commercial personal
uses thank you so um
regarding your um hello uh thank you
council barry
so regarding the second question i
don't have the kind of information but
there is already a 14 peaches
caravan sides on the kind of larger side
um so that's where
there's already anyway
[Music]
such a site um
[Music]
i i don't know why the six caravan um
pitches um were not uh
put here after the appeal but uh the
i know the applicant uh is um is happy
with the 14 pitches
uh and you know they got their own
community and
is is very happy and um what he wants to
do is actually
um produce rural local jobs and
a business and but obviously you would
have to ask the applicant
why they have not uh uh you know
progressed
uh with um uh with the six speeches
if you are referring to the six uh
caravan pitches
yeah of 2014 i i don't have the answer
to that but i know there is um
14 pitches already as well in the kind
of larger site
um and regarding the uh
the welfare donation neighborhood
development plan i don't have that
information
and but can be
i can research that and and send back
but um
i'm not sure whether we got policies for
uh
in in the actual neighborhood
development plan and
for uh businesses but there is there are
policies as councilor carter said
uh in uh for development um
in open countryside but my point is that
this site uh was you know for as a
commercial side
is you know is referred as um
unsustainable and in open countryside
but i just quoted
from the report which i think yeah we're
straying away from the question that's
asked i think you've asked those now and
i i
whilst i appreciate what you're saying
you have had an opportunity to say that
already so i think we can move on
um members do we have any other
questions for our counselor please
no okay in that case counselors go thank
you very much do feel free to stay on uh
online and continue to observe as we
deliberate
okay members let's move now into points
of clarification for our officers do we
have any questions for louise councillor
jennings first please
thank you very much chairman i thank you
question which everyone's got asking it
i mean this is a bit of um
[Music]
discrepancy as to whether it's
greenfield or brownfield
um could you just confirm that it is
greenfield
there um yes it is classified as
greenfield
and uh whilst discussion has been
occurring i on on a separate laptop have
been referring back to
the committee report which has been um
quoted
um from um various um
counsellors now um it is greenfield
it is a form of horticultural use
uh unfortunately i haven't got uh
your agendas uh but i've just got my own
printed off version so i don't quite
know what
page number it will be on but under
under the section uh principle of
development and
in in the key issues the uh
two fourth paragraph uh
fourth fifth and sixth paragraph of the
report goes through
uh the issue of whether or not agricult
horticultural uses e a b it even if they
are no longer in use
is still defined um as being green field
sites
um that i i've before going forward with
this application
i i went through and referred back to
previous case law
and uh that certainly was clarified um
in in terms of uh i i'm aware
that the suggestion that i had put
forward in a previous report
is it's not being brownfield however
i've read that same report in
the consideration on impact character
and appearance
uh on local aryan street scene it
i definitely specify that as i've
repeated in this application
it's a former horticultural use and it
is not defined therefore as previously
developed
it it is within that um that application
and was subsequently brought forward
since thank you very much luis for
members
attention that's on the top of page 13
of your reports
okay council adam next please thank you
um it's maybe related it's um i was
wondering about the
use of the the horticultural business
that was on there
and if there was um a more active
say business
aspect of that apart from just the
horticultural activities
so uh i know that lots of nurseries sell
plants um would would that
change the assessment at all if it were
um that type of horticultural business
as opposed to just
what farmland would be classified as if
you see what i mean
unfortunately um since certainly
um my um
employment with the council i have not
known the site to be occupied so
it's been an historic use so
unfortunately i'm not able to answer how
it
previously operated except from the fact
that it's formal
well it's lawful use of that area of
land remains to be
uh former horticultural use
okay that's useful thank you thank you
very much both castle mills next
please thanks ms germain hi louise uh hi
i i probably follow you on from the um
green field is it greenfield is it not
would you mind getting that fed
the aerial shot up for me again please
um of of the
all the sites that are butting that um
oh it's not letting me open application
uh
let me open a shed
sorry i think it's slightly further down
from this
am i going right no yes it's there there
we go
that's it yeah thank you so um
that where it says reads interiors and
designs that's
obviously you're saying that's not
greenfield
no no um the if i can
this is brownfield land joining this is
uh commercial uses
so that site that application site is
it's greenfield
and just beyond that the top of that
that's all greenfield as well is it
the whole area yeah this this area here
uh comprised of the the former um um
uh horticultural use this is this is
where the rainbow nursery holdings
um um comprised
the area to the rear they have had
planning permission
uh quite some time ago in order to
have a change of use into um industrial
use
um which is subsequently changed to
the skip and waste transfer permission
that was
actually a county application because
it's regarding waste
i believe that was in 2017 granted
consent
so something is actually on that site
now it says skip company
yes that has historically um
it had had a permission it was it was a
change of use because there was
there was a previous building on the
site and it was via a change of use
application that historically it got
transferred across
okay thank you louise thank you very
much thank you both council parry next
please
thank you chair good evening louise um
i just wondered whether you might have
discovered in your research and
preparation of the committee report
whether this site was identified in the
welford neighborhood
development plan for employment
i'm not aware that they have i
identified
specific sites for various uses that
don't think it is included in their
document it's it's just more of a
general that
um i i
apologize because i haven't got the
document in front of me
um it was more i think just a policy
actually i shouldn't go further i don't
think there is
but i can't i can't confirm no that's
that's fine i know some
some uh parishes and towns preparing
neighborhood development plans
do identify potential sites for
employment uses
which then links back into their policy
i just wanted to make
doubly sure that there were that it
hadn't been identified as a potential
site
thank you lovely thank you council dixon
next please
uh thank you chairman uh louise um good
evening
good evening the the travellers site
that is already there
and uh gained permission at appeal
in 2016. i think that's the one is it uh
the 12 caravans
including six statics etc it's 14
caravans has been
permitted in total i was wondering
when it went to committee it was refused
at committee i'm wondering if the
recommendation at the time it might be a
very unfair question
was to re was to refuse from the
officers because it was thought to be
greenfield
and what the inspector possibly
considered when he allowed it as to
whether or not he agreed with it being
greenfield or indeed disagreed with that
impression but
i say that might be an unfair question
to you i think that's a very unfair
question
um we're not here to deliberate and
debate previous decisions
uh we're here to look at and deliberate
and debate the one that's in front of us
so um louise wouldn't have that
information i don't think anyway so
we'll move on i think
uh counselor adam please
thank you um i'm just reading through
your recommendations
uh louise on the planning balance um and
i i i noticed that obviously you you've
um
highlighted the the the benefit that the
local economy would have
from the from the proposal um
are are you able to just clarify sort of
the
the measure of that that you've been
able to assess
um based on what what has been proposed
um
just just in terms of how yeah
whether i appreciate the issues around
greenfield but
you know if if this were determined to
be
of significant weight to outweigh that
in in
instance uh i'm just intrigued to see
what sort of weight we could
attribute to that the economic aspect
well from my perspective um i we we do
have a policy that
um allows for in in encourages
um local employment uses
um but as so
in in those instances we can we can
place um
obviously quite a lot of weight on that
and
the general concept of allowing for
local employment
is is within the core strategy supported
but it is caveated so it's it is
identified
that within open country locations
such as this because it is not within
the built-up area of welford on avon
it's
neither is it um falling whilst it's
close to long marston it's not within
their built up area boundary
boundary either so therefore it is a
greenfield site
in the open countryside and referring
back to policy uh
cs22 um
the the policy does uh allow for scope
for
expansion of existing buildings which
has indeed
happened um with the the premises to the
north um
um west of the site um their the county
application they have allowed for a
relatively um minor but nevertheless an
expansion of that enterprise
however when you're on sites where there
is no
existing development there isn't a
policy presumption in order to
policy principle to support
that's really useful thank you very much
thank you
thank you both for that okay there's i
see no one else indicating their wish to
ask you a question louise so thank you
for that let's move into
the deliberation and debate who would
like to kick us off
council jennings please thank you
chairman
i mean uh to me it's all i mean this is
all about
about the green field um
so i'm not never happy um when when we
have to
dig up the green field as it were um
i know that previously
on the north of this the gypsy
permissions but
i understand that has there's different
legislation attached to that and it's
it's worked out in a different way um
the site is it's quite a substantial
site
obviously it's sandwiched between two
brownfield sites but
the end of the day is greenfield um
and and i can see
uh no material planning reasons to go
against the officer's
decision on this one um and i would
like to propose that we refuse this
planning application
okay thank you very much councillor
kendall please
thank you chairman uh i nothing but to
address what
council jennings just said i think for
me it's all about the green field
um definition here and i'm satisfied
that louise has
adequately justified that this is
greenfield land i'm
happy to second marvelous thank you very
much
kendall council curtis as a question or
a comment i think
thank you guys i'm slightly struggling
with this one because although
the designation may be greenfield
this is really a scrubby piece of
wasteland with old greenhouses falling
down on it
i don't know if anyone actually knows
this piece of land i
cycle past it fairly frequently and i
just
i'm just wondering posing the question
really
this this is not going to be converted
into a nature reserve
you know it's it's not a beautiful piece
of
greenfield land and i just wonder if
members have some ideas of what the
future of this
plot of land will be
or might be
i'm not sure that we can really answer
that say for we are making a decision
on whether this piece of land could be
for office use general industrial use
storage and distribution
so i guess we'll find out shortly um
casa parry is next
to speak thank you chairman
um i mean what i'd like to say is is it
certainly it's evident that louise has
done of
the officers louise and the support with
all the
other officers has done a very detailed
committee report um and at the end of
the day we've got a number of policies
here
that goes against this type of
development
in the open countryside i'm also mindful
that our gypsy and traveler plan
is out for consultation at the moment
and we also
have a shortage of gypsy
and traveller sites now obviously the
applicant
went to great efforts
to gain permission for um expansion
of the existing gypsy and traveller site
next door
um and certainly you know um
it's already been identified by the
inspector
as a as a suitable site for travelers
and gypsies where all are
against that all our policies go against
um this particular application so
on the basis of that and when we think
all the efforts
that have gone into developing our call
strategy
and the policy making behind that um
for me whilst i acknowledge um
there would be some uh local support
in generation of economy we don't even
know what type
of development this would comprise
because this is only just as an outline
stage
um so for me um i would have to go with
the officer's recommendation
on refuse and to protect this area
at least as as an area of greenfield
that's all i wish to say thank you
chairman thank you very much cancer
parry councillor fleming next please
well thank you chair um
listening to what the other speakers
were saying about
the decimation of local industry and
small businesses and whatever else
um it does worry me that that we can
dismiss those um in favor of what might
be
a gypsy and traveller site and also what
might be green space
and what might be open countryside and
uh so i'm very undecided on this one and
i think that
um i think what we're doing here is uh
is we're dismissing a potential
um to get local people back into work
when they build the
4 000 houses on long marston airfield
that's a handy little commute down to
there for some people that might want a
business
so from that perspective i'm very
undecided on this one
thank you thank you very much councillor
mills please yes thanks for chairman and
just like
um build it i'm i'm torn on this and i
have to say it it seems to be
sandwiched between industrial sites this
this
piece of land um like
is it greenfield is it brownfield i
really i'm
i mean louise is the expert on this but
uh
i'm a bit torn at the moment mr chairman
my um
my heart saying it's um
it should be okay to build on but i'm
i'm i'm still debating in my mind mr
chairman
but not happy at the moment thank you
thank you very much cancer mills cancer
crime
please um just very briefly
um councillor fleming and councillor
mills have basically said what i was
going to say um
yeah i'm keen to support local
businesses
uh particularly in rural locations uh
bearing in mind
what the country is going through and
what it will be going through
um so yeah it is a difficult one i find
this one's in the balance as far as i'm
concerned and
and that's no criticism of louise and
the team for doing an excellent report
and
doing the planning balance and
probabilities so um
yeah just add my comments to council
fleming and cancer mills thank you
thank you very much councillor crump our
last three speakers have all indicated
similar sort of things
um for what it's worth i i'm trying to
find
policy that would help support but i'm
struggling i would direct those three
that have just spoken to
cs 22 and policy as10
and see if you can find something there
we do need something substantial some
policy
reasons go against our officers
recommendation um
i'm struggling uh although i have a
similar uh
mind to you guys let me bring in our
next um
speaker who is councillor dixon thank
you chairman i
too would be uh favorable to uh trying
to support this
application um it is a situation whereby
it's rather it's a discontinued
agricultural use
in the open countryside and i don't see
agriculture coming back to it
and i don't see anything else happening
to it unless we actually do
grant something tonight but essentially
yes
i would love to see this site developed
thank you very much counselor adam next
please thanks
um i think the the the reason for my
questions focusing on sort of the
economic aspect and the previous use of
it is because
i think as most you know the other
members of
the express actually there is a desire
to increase economic activity if we can
um the only thing i can think of that
would um
possibly provide adequate planning
reasons to go against this
recommendation
would be further investigation into the
actual
usage of the business um to determine if
activity was carried out on the site
that wasn't purely
agricultural um because then it would be
within
um within the policies as we
uh as louisa set out um as being an
existing site that's already have that
activity on it
um because uh clearly you know the the
report's very diligent in in assessing
that otherwise but
in answer to my question you know
understandably
um it wasn't determined exactly what
type of business was on the site apart
from the nursery
so the only thing i could think of would
be to
defer it to to allow us to to
further investigate that that potential
for the site and if that's not found to
be the case
then it would be in line with the
recommendation if you see what i mean
um okay your thoughts on that
that's understood i mean the description
of the development tells us that it is a
proposal for office use general
industrial and storage and distribution
um i think that's as much as we can know
at this stage it is outlined
this is an in-principle decision um so
we don't
remember the previous usage of the site
sorry
and then the previous usage of the site
not the proposed i see i do apologize
okay um i'll leave that for members to
comment on if they
they feel the need um so just to very
quickly sum up um and i'll ask tracy to
add anything i may miss
uh we have a proposal uh that has been
seconded to refuse the application in
line with the officer's recommendation
there seems to be a general feeling that
we would like to support
uh this but we cannot find policy uh
in order to do so if we don't have
policy just
as a reminder to members then clearly we
should be refusing
um tracy is there anything else you want
to add to that at this point
thank you chairman i think that's a very
helpful summary obviously we've tried to
go through the issues in the report but
we have concluded that
in the offices view it is a greenfield
site that has previously been in
horticultural use
but the current application before us is
in outline and it
is for general industrial use offices
and storage and distribution
um our balancing of the issues towards
the end of the report
clearly we balance the uh policy
requirements
for open countryside development to be
overriding in this case given the
details of the application in front of
us
so officers are comfortable that uh the
first reason for refusal
is something that we'd be seeking member
support and we could defend
um if it got as far as an appeal the the
second reason refusal clearly is
is related to flood risk is on the
advice of our colleagues at the
llfa because it is an outline
application that issue does need to be
sorted out at
outline stage so i think some members
previously spoke about whether we could
condition that or leave it to reserve
matters
and i'd have to advise members that
wouldn't be appropriate because this is
the outline application assessing the
principle of development
uh flood risk would need to be sorted
out in detail at this stage
and the advice of us our council t on
that matter at the moment is that we
can't support it for those reasons
so i'm afraid we do have those those two
outstanding reasons in our
recommendation to you
thank you very much tracy okay we have
three more speakers um
i'm conscious that we have been uh
discussing this for the better part 45
minutes so
uh i will wrap it up after those three
and move to a
vote so councillor jennings first of all
please
no i'm sorry that she might i was going
to ask about uh the flood about the
flood
risk it's just been addressed it's been
dealt with no problem thank you
uh council curtis please yeah thanks
very much chairman uh just coming back
really on the
comment about it being open countryside
that does seem to be a matter of debate
rather than absolute black and white so
i don't know if that has any
impact on what the decision might be
i i guess that's down to the decision
maker um counselor parry
finally please thank you um chairman
my concern obviously is if we've got an
issue over the flooding that can only be
resolved
um if we have further information to
mean
we either have to go with a refusal this
evening or a deferment
pass okay thank you very much
um there being no further speakers uh we
have a proposal
it has been seconded um so we will move
to a vote the proposal is to refuse in
line with the officer's recommendation i
will start
there being no policy to support this um
council richards
iv thank you chairman councillor fleming
uh okay so flaring unfortunately i'm
going to abstain from this one thank you
very much
also kendall councillor handle four
councillor adam adam
hubstain councillor crump
council from pop stein councillor curtis
councillor curtis abstain
councillor dixon councillor dixon
against
i'd like to see a referral
counselor jennings councillor jennings
four
councillor mills councillor mills
against
and councillor parry councillor parry
for
regrettably on the on the basis of no
policy
thank you chairman that's one two that's
four votes
four three four
four votes four abstentions and two
votes against
thank you very much liz that's what i
had so therefore committee uh resolves
to refuse application twenty zero one
one three two
out thank you very much everybody right
let's move
quickly to our next item which is um
item number twenty zero one
eight six four ful that is bellfield
tamworth at twelve bellfield i should
say tanworth and arden
uh our presenting officer is louise
coleman louise
whenever you're ready over to you thank
you chair
right let me get rid of that one
before you start louise um members of
the
public that are registered
please one could you please turn off any
live streams they are
slightly delayed and will cause an issue
for us and if you could also mute your
phones your keypads by pressing star and
six
we are getting a bit of feedback uh
thank you very much for that
louise apologies whenever you're ready
over to you yep no problem it's
no problem at all um can everyone see
their screen
certainly can okay lovely um the
application site is identified by the
black dot in the map
and is located within the village of
tamworth and arden
it's uh identified by the site edged in
red
and is located within the west midlands
greenbelt in arden special landscaping
area residential properties surround the
site
with doctors close lying to the rear and
comprising of a mix of two-story
dwellings interspersed with
a number of garaging uh garaging being
here here
and uh uh well certainly
uh to the side here and we'll see some
photographs of some other
garaging as well and then the
residential properties within uh
bellfield
um to the north of the application
site with a bowling green to
the northeast
planning permission is sort for the
erection of a new two-bed bungalow
within the rear
garden of number 12 bellfield which is a
two-story
end of terrace property two car parking
spaces will be provided with the
for the proposed uh bungalow in a tandem
formation
and would be accessed from bellfield via
a private drive in front of number 10 to
12 bellfield
the host property number 12 bellfield
would retain sufficient space for the
parking of two vehicles
which is required for which is a
sorry uh 12 bellfield is a three bed
property
um and a footpath
also runs to this side of the
site which connects the bell field
to doctors close the garden is currently
enclosed by a 1.8 meter tall
timber fence which also faces onto the
footpath
and onto the surrounding open space
within doctors close
the proposal would result in an existing
opening on two
doctors close which is in this vicinity
here
being removed and the new dwelling would
front onto
doctor's clothes
this is a block plan of the proposed
dwelling
it shows two bedrooms look at master
bedroom here and a smaller
room here with a living room and kitchen
diner
the garden area would be located to the
uh the rear well of the of this dwelling
so the garden area to the s to the rear
here and also to the side
here the red dot
indicated on the plan um indicates the
area where a lawful uh proposed
development
is permitted which would be unable to be
implemented if the development
were to be permitted um and the rear
elevation of the host dwelling also
shows
um the outline of a two-story extension
um part two story i should say and part
single story extension
which would uh is proposed to be uh
continued to be uh carried out if the
development were to come forward um
at this juncture i am just going to
uh just provide you with an
update in relation to the um
uh the uh sorry the
the the fallback position as detailed in
the committee report
um the report makes reference to
uh three previous developments that um
are all included uh as part of the full
back position
in terms of design and distinctiveness
and it's concluded that all three
uh uh the report concludes that all
three could be implemented
now um this the the application
site also includes an extent permission
for a side extension which i'm going to
be showing you shortly
um so um what
we have determined as following a review
of the approved plans
is that officers consider that both of
the
side extension which is granted in 2019
and the rear extension
which is a 2000 permission which has
been suggested is going to be
implemented
couldn't be lawfully implemented um
simply because it would you couldn't
um carry out both and also be in
accordance with the approved drawings
this in effect will lessen the strength
of the full back position but
notwithstanding this
officers are still satisfied that the
overall design of the scheme is
acceptable
now this doesn't change the green belt
assessments which also concludes that
the proposal is acceptable
as limited in-field development
um turning now to uh the front elevation
of the property
um this is the view of the front
elevation which
would front onto doctors close so the
existing close boarded fencing is
proposed to be removed in front of here
a new hedgerow installed
moving on this sees uh some front
elevations of the property so the dotted
line here is the
uh the um the garage
profile um so you can see it in the
context with the bungalow
being proposed and this is
the two-story extension this is the
front elevation of the existing property
and the two-story extension
which um has been permitted into the
2019 permission
and which i've just verbally updated you
uh
that we consider that couldn't be
implemented together with the rear
extension
um so this is a view of the property
from bellfield
this single story extension would be
demolished
this is the area where the tandem
parking arrangement would be
proposed and again um
parking whilst it's not in this
particular photograph
would be perpendicular to the uh the
footpath here
on this private driveway
turning now this is a view from doctors
close so this is the gate
gated access which would be closed off
and
a new hedgerow installed within this
area
and this is an artist's impression of of
how the development would
uh would appear within within the site
confines with the rear extension
um proposed onto the back of the host
property and this is a view
of the existing dwelling so these
extensions will be removed
um and the access into the
property of the new new bungalow will be
in this
vicinity here with the dwelling situated
here and finally
just to give you context with um doctors
close
this is the footpath these are the new
houses and this is number 10
doctors close and the relationship
between the adjoining neighbors
um that's the end of the presentation
one of the additional elements is the um
sorry there is
a verb in addition to the verbal update
there are a number of updates to note
uh with some additional comments from
councillor dixon uh raising queries
regarding the access and the
car parking arrangements and the highway
authority's response
uh to the various queries raised
the recommendation is to grant subject
to the conditions and notes
as detailed in the committee report
thank you chair
louise thank you very much members as as
louise has mentioned there is a
substantial update in the update sheet
uh
you have obviously already confirmed
that you've read it but if you want to
familiarize yourself it's worth having
two hand
let's move to our first speaker on this
item who is councillor mike
saunders of tanworth in arden parish
council council saunders can you hear me
you may need to press star and six to
unmute your keypad
just to reiterate that star and six will
i meet you
counselor saunders can you hear me
star and sixth one mute to you
could i have confirmation from our
committee services that council saunders
has indeed been able to join our meeting
please
yes he has
counselor saunders hopefully you can
hear me i
can indeed welcome sorry for that
we can yes thank you very much can you
hear us okay yes i can hear you
marvelous you've got the live stream
running in the background if you could
stop that
uh how do i do that
you can either click pause mute or close
down the screen
i think i'll close down the screen okay
can you hear me now i can hear you loud
and clear that's much better thank you
thank you thank you chairman good
evening all right
good evening the number the parish
council's objection
is that this is too small
sorry before you dive in just to just
let you know you have three minutes and
we will give you a thirty second
i know that yeah i just i thought i'd
better make make it clear
essentially this is just simply too
cramped a site
the officer's very sarah report
by and large seems to conclude there's
not all the key aspects it just about
passes muster
but on all of them it's only just it
seems to me there are four areas first
of all
respecting the character the area um
there will be a loss
of sense of space it's already quite
cluttered as you can see from the plan
with other buildings very close
in all directions a particular
importance is the issue of parking
you will see that the access
to the site to the house is just a
blocked off cultivac
there's no turning area if cars are
parked as they should be
in number 12 it's hard to imagine
most people going to the trouble of
trying to draw into that little
two tandem parking area and then
reversing out
and the result will simply be more cars
will be parked
on the more open area of bellfield
and we've already had a great many
complaints over the last two or three
years
of inadequate parking space and damage
to the central green
in terms of amenities it seems to me
that the
new occupant as the bungalow is built
will suffer from a loss of privacy
um as to a lesser extent will the
occupants of number
11. the officer's report says that
minimum space standard garden standards
are met yes they're met just and nearly
a hundred is required and they've got
110
but that 110 is made up of all sorts of
little bits of strips of land around the
edge
corners areas of ground which
really will have lead little practical
use or enjoyment
and i wouldn't want to be a small boy
with a football and either of those two
properties
so to sum up uh one other point to try
to make
quite a lot is made of the fallback
position and the fact that there are
extant planning permissions
it is true that the building of those
will
in bulk terms be no will be
will be possibly even worse than the new
bungalow
but in all the other issues that i've
raised privacy immunity
garden space and parking those extant
permissions
are irrelevant and if anything they
might improve the position
thank you council saunders thank you
very much for that
members do we have any questions for
council saunders please if you could
indicate in the chat if you do
i see nothing happening at the moment
i'll give it a couple of more seconds
it looks like that's a no so council
saunders thank you very much for your
contribution tonight do feel free to
hang up the
handset and continue to watch on the
live stream online
yeah five six and hash isn't it uh star
and six yeah that's right thank you very
much
okay let's move then to our next speaker
who is mr
nigel kaylo the agent for the
application mr calo are you there can
you hear me
yes i can hear you chairman thank you
marvellous similar uh
state of play you have three minutes 30
second warning at the end and if you
could stay on for questions that would
be great
otherwise whenever you're ready feel
free to start thank you very much
uh good evening chairman and members
thank you for allowing me to speak i'm
nigel kahlo from nnjc design
principal designer on the project
speaking in support of our
clients application of it this windfall
site is set well within the village
environs of tamworth in arden outside of
the conservation area and surrounded by
residential properties
the application perfectly represents
limited infill and does not require
proven special circumstances to gain
approval
the proposal follows detailed
consultations and revisions which fully
address initial concerns raised by
officers
our artistic impression illustrate
comparisons which previously approved
schemes on the site
clearly demonstrating how the final
proposal creates less visual impact
the scale and the volume of the proposal
is significantly lower than the recently
approved schemes that could be built out
so this application cannot be considered
as over development as is proposed by
most objectors this development offers
no impact in terms of overlooking or
overshadowing either
and is appropriate to the site's context
and constraints
it is particularly acceptable when
considering the need to provide a
variety of dwelling types
to create a socially sustainable and
diverse mix of housing which all
authorities should strive to achieve
to ensure the long-term vita vitality of
regional villages
duly restricting the need to use the
wider greenbelt
all relevant design criteria have been
used and appropriate
closely scrutinized adjustments made to
ensure that the scheme fully accords
with or exceeds
local and national planning guidance
parking provision is in full agreement
with your highway officers requirements
and your planning officers are equally
content with the overall development
proposals
this is clearly defined in their report
to you having duly considered and
addressed all relevant
objections the key element of the design
is
preference to achieve an enhanced
experience with the use of the public
footpath link by a doctor's clothes
rather than having a confined alleyway
the proposed transitional link scheme
achieves a wider more open vista
while still providing a sense of
enclosure and privacy to the rear
gardens of all properties along the
southern edge of bellfield
with the provision of high quality
materials and robust building systems as
set out in the climate change checklist
permission would therefore
now be granted for a much improved
environmental and ecologically
beneficial development
above that of the extant permissions for
the site having cons
carefully reviewed all of the objections
we consider that there are no material
planning consideration arising from
those matters that would provide
appropriate reasons to refuse planning
permission
and in conclusion we've read your
office's detailed report and fully
concur with its recommendations
when considering the scheme in the
planning balance the design complies
with relevant policy
through providing a small scale bespoke
development which is a well-balanced
cohesive and
innovative scheme which will enhance the
character of the village environs
we due consideration to all those
matters given above and with respect to
your officers report
we respectfully request that this
application be approved by members of
this evening's meeting
thank you mr kayla thank you very much
for that
members do we have any questions for mr
kayla please if you could indicate in
the chat if you do
i'll give it a few seconds to see if
anyone wants to ask you a question
it looks like that's going to be a note
so mr caleb thank you very much for your
contribution this evening if you want to
hang up your handset and continue watch
online that would be great
thank you good evening thank you good
evening okay we'll move to our next
speakers councillor dixon
you know the rules five minutes 30
seconds stay on for questions when
you're ready
thank you chairman uh the bell field a
1950s housing estate
uh developed by the council comprising
about 27
properties the report does indicate that
there are driveways i regret to advise
you that there
are no driveways so there's not an open
area
and essentially but if uh looking at the
first photograph there which uh louise
has put up thank you louise
this is obviously the entrance to the
left of my car
is the entrance to the bowling green
and uh that looked to me to be
the uh the public highway when i parked
there
subsequent investigation shows from the
warwickshire county council
that that is not adopted highway but i'm
not quite sure who the ownership
is uh if you could put on the the slide
of the
general view of bellefield louise that
would be very useful
that was taken at the same time i simply
turned around that's the view of the
bell field
well and truly parked up parking is a
great issue
this was quite simply two o'clock on
monday
that black car is probably parked
outside number 11
and the red one outside number 10 the
entrance to
what is the short cul-de-sac there if
you could put on the next slide for me
uh
louise i'll be grateful uh now it's
interesting that
when i took that one monday i suspect
it's the same car that was on louise's
slide that she showed early from the
slightly different
angle um i take the view that uh
that was a not a particularly long car
the
borishie county council in their first
objection wanted to see that an mpv
could park
or get into the access for the bungalow
now obviously in providing access to the
bungalow we're left with having to
create two spaces
for the present number 12.
that car is occupying one of them slight
angle
and its others suggest slightly sticking
over the pavement
which led me to go up today to measure
the distance
from the house to the pavement uh it's a
private pavement private road
it may that may make a difference i'm
not aware that it does
but essentially the distance from the
wall to the pavement is four and a half
meters our supplementary planning uh
details require that a planning lot
uh on a drive should be at least six
meters long three meters wide
um the uh drawing from
the applicant's agents to workshop
county council for the
uh turning circle for an mpv gave the
length of an npv
as being 4.856 meters
and whilst that might possibly be able
to access the bungalow site
certainly an npv of that length or two
of them could not be parked in front
of number 12. in fact i think even an
estate car
as opposed to a hatchback would struggle
to park perpendicularly and not
have an interaction with the pavement
now when i actually look at the report
the report basically draws the
conclusion that it is
acceptable infill and it goes on on
page 28 as to
describe limited info technologies that
limited infill is not defined in the npp
f2019 or the ppg
and whether a development can be
considered to represent limited infill
in the village is a matter of planning
judgment ian golick the planner who has
now subsequently left
stratford district council made the
assumption that this was indeed limited
info i disagree as members of the
committee you too
can disagree he goes on in that same
paragraph a variety of appeal decisions
have provided an alternative definition
to infill
including small-scale development of a
plot of land
which fills a gap within an otherwise
built up area
as opposed to a gap along a frontage
i would suggest to you that this is not
a plot
of land which fills a gap within an
otherwise built up area
it is the garden and it is not a
particularly
large garden i know the agent might have
described it as a large garden
but one of the local residents put a
note through my
front door this morning and i read from
his
uh first paragraph i won't read it at
all i cannot believe that the proposal
to build a new bungalow in a 19-meter
back garden
has gone this far i had expected common
sense to prevail at an early stage
and to dismiss this out of hand however
that is not the case
and almost all-heartedly object to the
application later on it goes on to ask
the question
why are there several deluxe windows in
the loft space
is it for a future first floor
um i would ask the question of the
planning officer
what is the ridge height and could a
first
floor be introduced without the need to
seek further planning common sense i
think that probably wraps it all up
chairman thank you
thank you very much dixon questions to
our counselor please first up is
councillor parry
thank you chairman and uh good evening
councillor dixon
um i just didn't quite catch the full
length
of the the current driveway from the
wall
to the foot way i wonder whether you
could just reconfirm that for me
4.5 meters okay
thank you very much okay do we have any
other questions for our ward member
please
please indicate in the chat if you do
no one's moving so i'm going to assume
that you know council dixon thank you
very much do you stay on to observe the
rest and rejoin us shortly
okay let's move to uh questions of our
officer members do we have any questions
that you would like
to ask louise before we move to the
debates please indicate in the chat if
you
do cancer parry
thank you chair um
counselor perry i think your microphone
managed to mute itself there um we
didn't sorry
is there anything do please stop again i
just wonder whether you could reconfirm
the parking area
um that's in front of number 12
bellfield
please um and the
um current council guidelines on the
length
of the driveway and would i
would i be right if if vehicles actually
parked slightly
um if there was only one vehicle to
number 12 and they
they parked on a slight angle that
presumably would give more length
sorry so taking the first question so
you wanted
clarification about the uh parking area
i
assume that's the uh the length of this
car parking spaces
um is that correct council parry
yes please yes i'm not so concerned
about the one for the new development
i'm not concerned about
what's being left for the for number 12
the um for for the um bungalow
the plan indicates it to be
approximately 12 meters in length
um so certainly uh sufficient in order
to have a tandem arrangement
uh provided with respect to the
um the uh the host property number 12
that would um i think the plan um
scales up to be i think around about 4.6
4.7 meters
i i haven't personally measured it on
site however so
i wouldn't wish to dispute uh councillor
dixon's uh measurement there
okay thank you very much council fleming
next please
ah thank you chairman um it's all about
measurements and
uh louise can you put the picture up
before we go to that i'll ask the first
part of the question
um looking at where the house uh where
this new driveway is going to go
and seeing where i think the front door
for this number 12 is going to be
what's the distance from that house to
the edge of that driveway
so if you assume two cars are parked on
there
if the front door of the house becomes
on the side of the house
how much room is there between that
front door and then
and if two cars were parked on that
driveway
um unfortunately uh councillor i haven't
got that measurement
um to hand it it's something that i can
get out of the presentation and
potentially come back to you
with um but it it
looks as if it would probably be around
about a meter
um right okay okay and have you got the
picture uh showing the front elevation
of the house with
the existing extension please no no the
the original number 12 house
with the the lean two they're gonna
knock down oh
the photograph yeah please yes all right
yeah so making the assumption that where
that white front door is because i don't
see a door anywhere along the front of
the house
that the door into that house will now
be on the side
wall so if you have cars
going parking and going down to the
first available space they're going to
be driving very close to that front door
and it does concern me that if somebody
opens the front door and steps out
they're going to be reversed over or
whatever
and so that's why you know i'm asking
the question about that about the
distances between what i assume
will be the new front door once that
extension's gone
and when cars are parked on that new
driveway
um i can only go from
the the the plan that i have in front
i can only assume quite the same as
yourself
that that yes that access will be um
joining the um
the the the sorry the proposed driveway
i'm just trying to see
um it doesn't indicate any alteration to
the frontage
of their property so i assume it would
be on the side um
but i can't verify the distance okay
thank you very much i'd be a bit
it just makes me a little bit weary
about safety and access really
thank you thank you very much both
councillor curtis next please
oh thanks louise i wonder if you can
help me on this
um on page 31 it says um
you described the the the host property
is the existing house there
can you just clarify for me um
this new building would it
could it be sold then would it be a
completely
separate dwelling that could be
sold on as a as a separate freehold
um i believe so yes right
so i mean again now going back to
council flames boy
if it's a if it then becomes a
completely separate dwelling
there is no we can't really limit the
number of cars that
the owners of those properties may have
so it does just seem
very very cramped thanks very much
louise thank you
thank you chair no problem thank you
both for
that um there are no no one else is
indicated in the meeting chat they want
to ask a question louise if i may
very quickly ask about the back of the
host dwelling number 12 there are
presumably
upstairs windows i see you've talked
very briefly about the 45-25
rules the 45-25 so that does that apply
to
other windows into other dwellings or
does that include the gardening
the garden area and the reason i ask
that is i'm concerned that there might
be some overlooking of the residential
amenity for this bungalow
if you could clarify please
louise are you still there have you
frozen
i've got a horrible horrible feeling
louise's internet may have gone down and
we've lost her
and give her a couple of seconds louise
if you could respond either through the
chat to let us know you're still here
okay um technically speaking i think we
have to adjourn until we can get louise
back in
uh so i'm gonna call for a german just
for two minutes while we try and phone
louise and see what's
going on uh if we could pull up the
adjournment screen online that'd be
great
you will still be able to be heard
cancer so if you could please mute your
microphones that would be helpful
could we bring up the adjournment slide
if that's at all possible
please
uh can you hear me chairman
tracy the chairman's gone into the other
meeting
um he's asked you if you can go in he
wants to discuss it with you
okay everyone it looks like sadly we
have uh lost contact
with louise uh through teams and we're
struggling to erase her through
our uh telephones as well so um
with that uh i believe the right process
now is to invite
our planning manager tracy to take over
from louise
tracy can you confirm that you're there
and that's okay with you
thank you chairman yes apologies i did
respond in the chat but you've moved
into the uh
the other chat function um i will uh
obviously try to help members as far as
i can yes so
please ask away marvelous um so the
question i asked was about the back of
the host dwelling number 12
clearly there's going to be some windows
uh
my concern is relating to overlooking of
the the proposed new dwelling
i've seen reference to the 4525 rule in
the the report but it doesn't make much
of it
um should i be concerned about the
garden area in the residential community
area or should it only be about looking
through windows into
other buildings other properties
thank you chairman i'd acknowledge that
i haven't visited the site but looking
at the report
the case officer has gone through the
residential amenity impacts
both in terms of the future occupies of
the proposed bungalow
and the occupiers of the host building
incidentally it also talks about impact
on remaining neighbours in in perhaps
more depth
um the office's conclusion which in
fairness wasn't louise louise is the
presenting officer tonight the original
case officer has
has since left us um concludes that the
development
is acceptable and the separation
distances which are set out in our
development requirements spd
are met so i would conclude that
the development in terms of impact
from the both the adjoining property
onto the proposed property and vice
versa is within acceptable limits
and as i say that i think luis has just
rejoined us so
in fairness uh whether louise can
actually say more than i've just offered
there
possibly not okay we'll we'll put it to
louise now
um louise i understand you've had
technical difficulties don't worry it
happens
um we've managed to carry on anyway uh
we haven't really got further than uh
than when you got cut off i think so i
asked you a question about the
uh overlooking from number 12 onto the
new
property um i see reference in your
report to the 4525 rule
um am i concerning myself about the 4525
looking
into people's other people's houses or
is it also covering
garden areas or residential immunity
you are muted at the moment just so you
know
um sorry tracy have you have you made a
comment on this
only insofar as as reiterating what has
it said
what was in the report but
that no i would have i wouldn't have
anything to add to that unfortunately
because i i wasn't the original
committee
the officer uh i'm not the case officer
i should say
that's fine no problem thank you um we
do we've got two more questions
uh one is from councillor adam so
council adam you want to go first
thank you um and thanks louise um
it was to a point that councillor dixon
raised
um and part of the recommendation um as
to this being
an infill site now i think i mean
if that yeah that is a matter for
planning judgment and i think
this is something i'm slightly concerned
about so could you just say
if it was judged that this wasn't a
suitable infill site
would that be adequate in your mind to
change the recommendation
um tracy i think actually could you
assist on this one
you chairman yes sorry just checking
that uh that i'm not muted
um i think we've assessed within the
report that
limited infill uh would be acceptable in
in
in policy terms and the issues which
contribute to our assessment on that is
essentially the
the scale and massing of the proposal so
it is an issue and sort of judgment
um uh on the decision maker as to
whether they feel
uh the proposal meets a definition of
limited infill or not
officers conclusion on balance is that
it does
it is open to members if they wish to
draw an alternative conclusion on that
point
but officers do feel looking at that
policy and also
the distance separation issues and so
forth set out in the spd
um that the proposal is of a scale that
could be considered
limited infill thank you very much tracy
uh councillor parry as our final
question for officers
cancer parent thank you chair it's
really just
uh from a technical point of view if the
road
is not deemed as adopted highway
um what are the what are the
what is the situation if someone is
parking and overhangs onto the footway
because of the the length of it and just
out of interest
i have two cars one of which is a small
mercedes at four and a half
meters and the other one is a little
smart car which would be perfect
but that's at 2.7 meters but
i have a small hatchback which is 4.5
meters in length
and based on the measurement that
councilor dixon raised of four and a
half meters
in order to park and not damage the
front of my car
it would have to overhang on the
pavement
so-called if it was pop-up
part um in a vertical
uh perpendicular 90 degrees to the
property
but the road is not a is apparently a
private road so
does that allow someone to overhang
to park
with it with an overhang onto the onto
the footwear
tracy are you happy for me to answer
this uh by all means louise i can sum up
if members would like as well
okay um basically because it is a
private
um road and the footpath is also private
a
slight overhang onto that um private
road
would be considered to be acceptable
that's fine okay
uh very good uh there are no more
questions for you at this point louis so
we will move into
our debate uh who would like to kick us
off with some debate
please indicate in the chat to whoever
would like to go first
counselor adam was first in so cancer
adam
thanks um i think that obviously they've
sort of worked to quite a lot of
the the standards by which we will
balance these and
i'm sort of satisfied on some of them
but there are some aspects which
which do make me slightly uncomfortable
parking not least
um but i think when when looking at the
site um
at large and so i reference the actual
plan of the surrounding area
i am concerned that we are considering
this as
limited infill when i don't think that
is
necessarily how i would define it i mean
it
isn't a garden as as councillor dixon
raised and the the actual bungalow
itself
would be adjacent to what looks like a
driveway at the rear of another
road and it just doesn't feel that that
suitably
meets the sort of criteria of limited
infill
in and of itself i mean i i'm just just
to that
so i'll get the um the relevant page of
the report
i appreciate that there are other
definitions from just being within
uh the space between two properties um
and that's
it um could be a small scale
plot of land which fills in a gap but i
don't feel that this adequately
is classified as a gap in that area
because it's not on a frontage
it's not forming a void in the street
scene or anything like that
so that's my main bone of contention
along with the the ward members comments
really um
and that along with the other
reservations which have been raised by
other members
um particularly parking and potential
impact on
on the neighbors i think i'm i'm really
uncomfortable
with it on that basis um i'd like to see
what other members
opinions are as well but uh at the
moment i'm
i'm considering going against the office
of recommendation on that basis
okay thank you very much castle parry
next please
thank you chair i've i've got concerns
about this
this particular um proposal
um i know the officers have looked at it
and
to me it's more about the
the area of parking and it just feels
over development of the site from my
perspective i'm concerned
that there would be a front door on the
side which opens directly
onto the the parking area
which when officers looked at it
they're not actually looking at the plan
seeing the front door there
and um so i've got major concerns
because i think the only way you can
actually
whilst i acknowledge that you can park
the car
on the front of number 12 and overhang
onto the
to the pavement um i think that's going
to have an impact on the character of
the area
because you'd have to park to two cars
and they wouldn't they would of course
overhang
plus plus i'm not happy about the
the driveway i think to be honest with
you the site would be better
would be better accommodated by you know
going with the existing permission of of
of extension around the back because at
least then you wouldn't have
all the parking paraphernalia so um i'll
see what other people
have what other members have to say but
i am concerned
about it from over development of the
site and the cluttering then
having an impact on the character of the
street scene
thank you chair thank you very much
councillor parry councillor mills next
please
thanks richard actually anne's just
probably said what are you going to say
it just looks
looks wrong to me um it is
to my mind over development of the site
um
i'm considering going against the
officer's recommendations chairman thank
you
again sir curtis next please
counselor curtis you are muted at the
moment
thank you sorry thank you um yes
pretty much an agreement um i think you
know the the
comment on page 28 um
in filling in a village is a matter of
planning judgment so
that does seem to give some leeway to
the committee to make a
judgment um i think i can't remember
which which officer i think louise said
that members can draw an alternative
conclusion and so a bit of leeway there
as well
um i am concerned that this isn't just a
sort of
a granny flat if you like but it it can
be sold
on as a separate freehold so there's no
real control over the future
of this site and something i i just
thought at the end and wanted to ask a
question but it's a little bit too late
um i've got a question over access for
emergency services
if there are so many cars and there is
such
a tight area i think that that that
would concern me as well
thank you joe thank you guys curtis
council fleming next please
ah thank you jimmy um the
the the comment about the cars
overhanging from the front garden
from the front driveway onto the
pavement next to this new
site is uh is a footpath that goes down
the side of it so
it's you know it's not like there's
only going to be the residents walking
up and down there
and that there's going to be people who
go to that footpath and go down to this
this doctor's place at the back so it
could well be a fairly well worn path
that
and if you've got cars overhanging i
don't think that's a particularly good
thing to do
um and i've already mentioned about the
the worry about
uh stepping at your front door and there
being a big people carry a part there
and you can't actually get out very well
so
so i think you know access is the
biggest thing for me
plus the over development it's just an
obvious one but that's just a personal
opinion at the moment and
again i i'm not sure i can support the
officers on this
thank you thank you councillor fleming
council jennings next please
thank you chairman and i'll be honest i
don't have a problem about what happens
to it all
but what happens to the property
afterwards whether they sell it on or
whatever that's
really not relevant i don't think to us
um
a lot of infills are in gardens um
but at the same time i do look at this
and
it does seem very very cramped
um possibly access into the
into number 12. i i
struggle to see how they're actually
going to get in there unless they
actually move
the door to the front of the property
but i haven't put that into this
application
but main highways haven't objected to
this i'm sort of
it i feel uncomfortable but i don't
see how i could go against i'm
struggling to see what my material
planning objection is
um i don't know whether and again
safety as to whether when they they go
into number 12
is that a material planning matter i
don't
um i think if the officers have judged
it
that it is suitable it's all i'm doing
is saying all in my opinion
but i said uncomfortable with that
but i'm also uncomfortable with going
against the officer's
um ruling on this so i'm
i'm sort of getting splinters at the
moment
thank you very much cancer jennings um
that no one else has indicated their
wish
to speak at this point so i'll come in
and give my two points worth um
this there seems to be a general
direction of travel in terms of people's
thinking
um from from what everyone has said thus
far and
i'm inclined to agree with the vast
majority
um i'm struggling to agree with the
infill argument uh by virtue of the fact
that it is
uh within built form and therefore
uh i can only determine infill and one
bungalow is limited
um so i'm i wouldn't include infill in
any proposal
um over development at the site i
couldn't agree more i think it is a
vast over development of the site um
parking i have an issue with both in
terms of its
location its sizing uh and accessing
through to
uh the proposed new development um and
uh i particularly have an issue over
residential amenity notwithstanding the
fact that
the minimum garden areas have been met
or so we're told it is disjointed and
all over the place but also
uh in my view number 12 does very
clearly overlook
uh the proposed new development uh new
dwelling and it's
specifically its gardens i have a big
issue with that
so for those three reasons
or did i possibly say four um i'm
proposing that we refuse
planning commission uh for number 12
belfield
in tamiltn arden and i would seek a
seconder
councillor paris seconded would you care
to speak to that
now i'm fine chairman i did highlight
over development of the site and my
concerns
on the on on the proposed development
would have actually on the character
of the the area as well because i think
the impact of the way the
the parking of the cars and onto the
pavements and the residential immunity
appreciate highways haven't haven't
objected
but i still think it's over development
to the side okay
thank you very much um now tracy you've
heard the three or four reasons i can't
remember how many i said now
i think it was three reasons for uh
refusal
um the parking one i need to get the
wording right on i can see you've
you want to make a comment on that so do
you want to make it first of all do you
want to make a comment on
uh the reasons for refusal are you
satisfied that i've given appropriate
ones
for our policies um and then talk about
the parking one
thank you chairman yes according to my
notes you've listed three potential
reasons for refusal one is over
development
one is access and parking and the third
would be
residential amenity clearly if you were
to
um wanting to refuse the application on
any of those grounds we need to know
which policies of the core strategy
you're looking to uh to base those
concerns on
perhaps i could ask members to just give
some thought as to as to which ones
you're
specifically considering just in
relation to access and parking i know
there's been quite a bit of debate about
in particular the replacement parking
for the existing dwelling
um and whether the depth of frontage is
sufficient to provide
safe parking we've been back to county
very recently on that matter
and they have looked at it for us and
they're not raising objection
it is fair to say that there might be
some element of overhanging
over the footpath but as long as that
footpath is not a public footpath
it does not give rise to a highway
safety objection
which county are recommending we should
refuse the application on
so from a parking perspective and a
highway safety matter officers don't
feel
that we could safely recommend to you
that there is a highway safety
reason for refusal for that parking
arrangement
okay we don't necessarily have to agree
with that though do we
indeed not we would have to potentially
defend us disappear
understood um it is one of three um so
let's talk about the other two first so
overdevelopment site
uh in his first instance we've uh used
that as a reason for a future before but
i can't really
remember what the uh cs policy was are
you able to guide us on that please and
similarly with the residential amenity
i'm trying to find it now but i can't
i'm afraid i'm struggling
if i can oh am i on mute no
yes please sorry yeah see policy cs 9 of
our core strategy
generally talks about um it includes
about residential immunities
so i would direct you towards that
policy yeah that's design
and distinctiveness isn't it so yeah
that cover that can
that would cover both residential
immunity and over development on the
side i think
yes um and then i would direct you
towards uh
parking um that well that could
potentially fall under
a cs20
25 or 26 i do apologize one's
open space i think it's 26.
okay cs26
is transport communicator yeah transport
communication so that's correct yeah 26.
um okay remember do we want to talk do
we need to talk more about parking or
are we
satisfied that uh we're unhappy with the
parking arrangements by virtue of its
location design
uh and access through i have some
feedback
from my members on that
i've seen lots of nodding faces for
those that can't see so i'm assuming
everyone's happy
so on that basis let's move forward with
this so i've made a proposal
um to refuse the application on the
grounds of over development
uh residential amenity the impact it has
on it by virtue of its overlooking to
the new development
um but also the disjointed uh
garden area amenity area of both
notwithstanding that they meet our
minimums
um and finally parking so that's cs9 and
cs26
that has been seconded by councillor
parry uh councilman mills has indicated
his wish to speak very quickly so i'll
call him in now before we move to a vote
council mills
no miss gems okay it was it says
something about the park in the overhang
um it doesn't matter no i think really
good go looks like we're going through
anyway doesn't matter okay uh in that
case let's move to a vote so the
proposal is to refuse as i've outlined
council richards fourth
thank you chairman councillor fleming
coaster flowering four thank you
councillor kendall
councillor kendall four councillor adam
adam paul council crump
for councillor curtis
council curtis for councillor jennings
councillor jennings abstain
councilor mills council meals for
and councillor parry councillor parry
four
that's eight votes for um chairman
and one abstention fabulous thank you
very much for that
and therefore committee resolves to
refuse application twenty zero one
eight six four ful for the reasons we
have just
set out let's move to our next
application
um i'll just remind everyone before we
do we must start
our final application before 8 30. um
any applications that uh are left after
8 30 will i'm afraid be deferred
to any future meetings so please bear
that in mind when we are
uh discussing and deliberating things if
we can be concise
uh we we should be okay right so next
application is application reference
twenty zero two four four six
ful fifteen bernal close and bid for
uneven our presenting officer is
sarah mcpherson sarah over to you
thank you
can you see this okay certainly can okay
so this is a full planning application
for demolition of one dwelling and
erection of two detached dwellings
the site is
hello hello hello hello hi
sorry um i i think you may be registered
to speak this evening
um we are we're currently listening to
our presenting officer if you can press
star and six on your keypads to mute
yourself
uh then we uh hopefully we should be
able to hear from you at the appropriate
time
if your press starts to mute
thank you very much sarah sorry about
that do you want to carry on
yes can you see my presentation uh we
can yes thank you
perfect um this is a full planning
application for the demolition of one
dwelling and erection of two detached
dwellings
the site is identified here by the red
line the primary constraint is
smallbrook
which you can see is the blue line here
the black dot identifies the site within
the context of biblionavon
a main rural centre within the course
strategy
this area should illustrate where the
site is located within bidford
indicated by the red circle on the left
and here is the existing site plan next
to an aerial view of the site
here is the proposed site plan the red
dashed line
indicates the footprint of the existing
dwelling plots one and two will be laid
out next to one another
with plot two on a slight angle there
will be an open
carport at the entrance to the site with
two spaces within
and a further speed three spaces on the
drive note the purple hatching which
shows the extent of flood zone 3
and that the houses are within flood
zone 1 only
here are the proposed front and rear
elevations
here are the floor plans where you'll
see that plot one is to be a three bed
and plot two a four bed
here are the side elevations and also
the elevations for the open carport
turning to site photos this photo shows
the dwelling as you approach down the
close
here is the existing property
[Music]
this photo was taken looking towards the
site entrance as indicated on the plan
this photo was taken looking towards the
western end of the garden
this photo was taken from the rear
garden looking towards
the neighbouring property number 13.
that's the end of my presentation and i
draw members attention to three updates
on the update sheet
marvel sarah thank you very much for
that let's move to our
first speaker who is councillor taylor
from bidford on ivan parish council
council taylor are you there you may
need to press start and 6
to unmute yourself
i had a brief moment hello hi
i can indeed welcome uh this evening
you'll have three minutes
uh to speak we'll give you a 30-second
warning when your time is approaching
its end and
otherwise uh whenever you're ready do
feel free to start thank you very much
um good evening chairman and councillors
um
uh bidford press council has objected on
foregrounds
um flood risk over development of the
site height of the proposed houses
and lots of privacy flooding and over
development are the main concerns
and are interrelated actually the report
um to the committee states
the full report states that the plot is
partly in zone one where the houses
would be built
and partly in zone three um which is
where the highest risk level is where
the driveway foot pods
three car parking spaces and two
carports would be created
you'll note from the plants that the two
large houses propose to squeeze very
close together on a narrow part of the
plot
in order to just get them into the zone
one area
um the report also says says that the
the brook which
runs alongside the site flooded in 1998
but there was also another flood in 2007
when there was extensive flooding
especially along burnell close
floods in the bidford area becoming more
frequent and more extensive
including 2016 and 2019 and in 2019 the
brook actually broke its banks
in relation to the over development the
parish council is concerned that the
footprint of the replacement dwellings
and
carports take over most of the site
the driveway three parking spaces and
two carts would cover an additional land
area considerably bigger than the
footprints of the two houses themselves
and removing areas that soak in excess
water will only exacerbate the flood
risk
not only to these properties but also
the neighboring ones
as is acknowledged in the flood risk
assessment and i quote
given the whole site is expected to
flood in the design event
the potential impact of the development
on others will need to be managed
the flood risk assessment mentions the
possibility of permeable surfaces but
there's no commitment nor condition that
permeable services must be used for the
driveways parking and carport areas
with climate recharge resulting in more
frequent and heavier rainfall the issue
of flooding is high on the agenda of
bigfoot parish council
and the local community and any
development that can adversely affect
areas is strongly opposed
there's also the loss of amenity for
particularly for number 13 brunel close
next door
the conservatory and lounge face south
west the plot
one house would directly overlook both
leading to a lot of light
with a two-story high wall 7.8 meters
from the lounge window and 3.7 from the
conservatory
the applicant's planning statement
actually appears to ignore the impact of
the conservatory or to get on the
conservatory altogether
um in summary in summary the council
trusts that you will consider its grave
concerns in respect of the over
development
and consequent additional flood risks
that are based on local knowledge of the
area
and that you will refuse permission
thank you very much
casa taylor thank you very much for that
uh members do we have any questions for
our counselor
please if you could please indicate in
the chat
counselor mills please
thanks mr chairman oh um good evening
councillor
the um i remember the floods uh vividly
in 98
and 2007. are you saying with that if
when the floods came then did that flood
that area where the proposed
um homes are going to be put
right well that's a bit before my time i
know that the close
itself was absolutely flooded in 2007
but i might direct that to i think our
ward member is going to speak
after me so it might be better okay for
him to answer that
okay thank you okay do we have any
further questions for councillor taylor
i'm seeing nothing in the chat i'll give
you another couple of seconds
no one's moving so i'm assuming that's
it counselor taylor thank you very much
for your contribution this evening if
you want to hang up the phone now and
continue to watch on the live stream
that would be ideal thank you again
thank you very much thanks okay uh our
next speaker is mr colin
parr a resident uh who is under our
objectives list
mr parr are you there can you hear me
you may need to press start on six
to unmute your phone hello hello good
evening is that mr
uh mr parr
oh we've lost you again and
fabulous uh welcome this evening um i
don't know if you've done this before
but just to let you know you've got
three minutes to speak and we'll give
you a 30 second warning
otherwise whenever you're ready feel
free to start
okay thank you uh good evening
councillors um my name is colin parr
i'm a resident at number 13 burndown
close adjacent to the proposed
properties
i've been a resident here for 25 years
so i've seen quite a bit in terms of
flooding
i have four elements of objection to
flag
firstly privacy impact and the adverse
effect on the neighboring immunity
and the plans for plot one with a north
east
facing window be on the second floor of
the three bed dwelling
directly overlook both into my lounge
and conservatory
i have provided a photograph as best as
i can
which would show the intrusion but it
obviously doesn't quite catch the
elevation view as i was stood on the
ladder
but this is less than eight meters in
distance to my property
the plan states that the room will be
used as either study or a bedroom
and already or will have a skylight to
provide light
no other house in the close has such an
intrusion um
with a view directly into their lounge
or into
their conservatory i raise this matter
but it doesn't actually feature in the
report at all
but i cannot see why a window would be
put in there
and would be allowed to overlook into
enabling property
my second point is loss of light and
then again an adverse effect on enabling
immunity
and we had a conservatory built to
benefit from the south and southwest
sunny position
but the wall of the new dwelling which
will be slightly higher than my house
due to um
uh meeting requirements from the flood
risk report
will it be only a mere 3.7 meters away
which will severely impact the levels of
sunlight receiving to my conservatory
the committee report focuses on the
light impacts on my lounge
with an observation that i have two
windows one on the side of one of the
fronts
but there is no mention of the impact of
this on my conservatory
my third point relates to the flood risk
the environmental report recognises
there's a high risk
for the access road point directly
opposite my house to flood
i provided the photograph because
surface water
gathers here drains into the grid and
then goes into the brook
but if the brook is full it backflows
into the road
there was previous references to did it
have we had flooding before
yes flooding to the lower level my house
occurred twice
in 1998 and 2007
and equally significantly we've had
numerous buildups of
significant surface water recently which
fortunately
hasn't entered the property but every
time a very large
pool starts to emerge the additional
hard standing for car parking
carports and any paths or other
landscaping in time
will severely restrict the ability for
the water to drain away
my final point is i see this as an
overdue melons of the 15 burnell close
site
i'm aware there is a covenant in place
which restricts building on the north
east side hence the four bed and the
three bed
have been have been pushed forward and
the three bed is proposed to be built
upon garage foundations
rather than existing bungalow foundation
this in turn pushes the property in
question much closer to boundary edge
and impacts adversity on my property
i'm gonna have to stop you there um that
is uh just over your three minutes
and if you've got a very quick 10-second
wrap-up i'll be happy to listen to that
but otherwise we're going to have to
stop you
sure yeah the final statement was
overall one large house rather than two
houses would be a much better fit
thank you lovely thank you very much
members do we have any questions for mr
par please
please indicate in the chat if you do
i'm seeing five or six shaking heads
cancer dixon
thank you chairman uh mr parr um do you
have the officers report in front of you
at all um i'm looking at the plan
at the end of the report i'm trying to
ascertain in my own mind
where that conservatory of yours is is
it
the point of that your property as it
were pointing towards
the development plot or is it on
if you like the normal back of the
property no it's on the side of my house
directly pointing towards the property
thank you very much because that so you
you get
some from both sides and obviously the
end is the part that would be most
materially impacted
yeah i mean obviously as the sun moves
around yes but the
the property would take away a lot of
the sunlight that would move through
throughout the day
okay thank you very much okay no one
else is
germany muted
forgive me for that uh mr pass thank you
very much there's no one else has
indicated their desire
to ask you a question so uh
thank you very much for your
contributions this evening if you want
to hang up your handset now
and uh continue to watch on the live
stream that would be perfect
thank you again okay thank you
marvelous okay let's move to our next
speaker who is uh miss jane
cashmore our agent ms cashmore are you
there
i am yes can you hear me i certainly can
uh now you get the benefit of six
minutes this evening um with a 30 second
warning towards the end
whenever you're ready do feel free to
start thank you good evening
thank you for the opportunity of
speaking the committee report before you
is comprehensive
and well written before putting together
any detailed plans
the applicants engaged in
pre-application discussions with the
district council
positive feedback was given the
applicants also spoke with several
nearest neighbours to advise them of the
proposal in advance of the plans being
submitted
at that stage they were not advised of
any objections
the site lies within the multiplayer
boundary of biddeford the main rural
centre
and is a sustainable location for a net
gain of one dwelling
it's recognized that change or
development is often unwelcomed within a
but change in itself is not a reason to
prevent development
there must be planning harm the
committee report comprehensively
addresses the local planning objections
raised
in brief over-development would not
arise
as you can see from the site location
plan it is a larger plot than others on
burnout close
the development makes more effective use
of the land which is promoted by the
mpps
it can accommodate the two dwellings
proposed whilst creating adequate
separation
and garden sizes burnout close is mixed
in character
to the south side which is the
application size the properties are
two-story with the exception of the
application site
introducing two stories at this location
is therefore in keeping with the street
scene
the existing dwelling is a dormer
bungalow and approximately six meters to
ridge
the proposed dwellings are approximately
7.2 meters to ridge
the design is simple and material
similar to those within the close
minimum separation to neighbours is
achieved and your officers were
satisfied that the proposal would not
detract from the amenity of
neighbours we've just heard from mr parr
and he's mentioned about the side facing
study window
and as you'll see from the update sheet
that is proposed to be obscure
and fixed shut and the applicants have
no objection to that
with regards to his side facing
conservatory you will see this on the
site plan
and this has been taken into account a
45 degree line is shown from the rear
doors which is not breached
and you'll also note from the
development requirements spd that
neighbours side-facing windows
are not normally given the same degree
of protection as front or rear-facing
windows
with regard flooding the application is
accompanied by a flood
bud consultant and the environment
agency raised no objection subject to a
condition
you'll note that the conditions in the
office report would require the
development
to be carried out in compliance with the
flood risk assessment
and the previous speakers have both
referred to permeable surfacing on the
driveways
the flood risk assessment does set out
that i just quote it's feasible to
achieve
well let me start the most sustainable
approach would be a direct discharge to
the watercourse with attenuation to
reduce the flood rate
it is feasible to achieve this by
utilizing permeable paving on the
driveways
to temporarily store all runoff with
controlled discharge to the watercourse
and that's within the flood risk
assessment which will be controlled
through condition
six local concerns about traffic are
noted but the council's parking
standards are met on site and county
highways have raised no objection
the applicants welcome a condition for a
construction management plan
there are no objections from
environmental health highways ecology
southern trent and the environment
agency
i hope you are able to support your
office's recommendation to grant and
thank you for listening
ms kashmir thank you very much for that
members do we have any questions for the
agent on the application
please if you could indicate in the chat
if you do that would be great
maybe a couple of seconds it doesn't
seem too much movements
uh jane it looks like uh there's no
questions for you tonight so thank you
very much for your contribution as
always and we'll hear from you again uh
in a couple of items
thank you very much thanks thank you uh
okay let's move
to our um award member who is councillor
fleming
council fleming
so casper you'll have five minutes 30
seconds warning the usual stuff
um whenever you're already do feel free
to start
sorry about that chairman i'm having a
bit of i.t issues
um before i get too into what i've got
to say um
my adjacent ward member has emailed me
and i think he emailed you as well
um and and the planning manager
to say that the the update sheet
doesn't bear any resemblance to what he
sent in as a report
and this has been muted and watered down
um he's getting very vocal about that
and
and i agree with him having seen the
other report it misses the
whole sort of concept and the whole uh
policy of h5
so i just want to make that very plain
to start with
um the next thing i'll go and do is what
i was gonna say
um is that um we don't have a housing
need for three to four bedroom houses
there are two large developments
still being built and are selling in our
village
this small brook can and does burst its
banks and is dangerously close to this
site
several times you know several times a
year um
it does get very close and does come out
of the just come out of its banks
i live only 400 metres away from this
site and
the flooding and it floods regularly the
environment agency assumptions and
records don't record every event as they
are not all reported
when we're now close was constructed it
was well designed
as a built up area boundary
leading open aspects to the to the
bottom end of
burnell close which is why there were
bungalows
around the left hand the right hand side
of the road
and also across the bottom and that's
the whole reason that they were
bungalows so that it leaves you an open
aspect to look over the countryside
um because the adjacent land is broome
court farm
and is quite perfectly flat for at least
half a mile
before it rises onto murray's hill um
this street scenes that we're talking
about street scene isn't just about
the aesthetics of a street scene you
know putting two houses
next to a house there's more to it than
that and this was designed in such a way
that uh that people could enjoy the
views over the countryside
and that's why bungalows were put in
that particular area
um there's only a real reason to make a
change if if it's going to improve or
whatever but
there's no reason at all to change this
concept the close proximity to his
existing house in number 13 and to doug
dale avenue
constitutes severe overlooking problems
and loss of privacy
over development by cube if not by
footprint
we have a lot of reference to the
footprint not being that much different
but it's about the cube as well
um you know i mean c59 lots of amenities
i mean that that's
that that's already been discussed so i
won't go into too much of that
but one of the main problems is they
raise the slab so they can raise the
level of the floor level of the houses
to try and mitigate this this flood risk
but that contributes greatly to the
overlooking from the upper floors
and the one of the most important things
i seem to see when looking at this plan
is that water is no respecter of blue
lines on a map
when the water's coming it's coming out
and uh and this
this small brook rises very quickly and
gives you very little warning you're
gonna get your feet
wet um i would urge the uh
the committee to refuse this permission
um because
uh i think it goes well against
just loc localism needs i mean
you know from a there are loads of
planning
reasons to do it but at the same time i
think that
local knowledge and local experiences
do tell an awful lot about this
particular site
thank you very much
thank you very much members do we have
any questions for our counsellor
please indicate in the chat if you do
no in that case uh thank you very much
councillor fleming please do stay on and
continue to observe and join us
after this application is concluded um
okay let's move to questions and points
for clarification to our offices members
do you have any questions or points that
need clarifying by our officers
councillor jennings is first up please
thank you chairman here's just a quick
one on the on the carports
being in zone three um
what effect does that does that have um
on this application
um the we have obviously consulted the
environment agency
there where the car parking and the car
ports is within zone
three they haven't raised an objection
to that the important point was that the
houses themselves are outside of zone
three
um i point out that the carport is
completely open-sided it's
a roof on stilts essentially um
and the hard surfacing for the driveway
including the carport can be agreed by
condition in the hard and soft landsat
landscaping scheme and to be a permeable
material
which would also be in line with the
condition requiring development to be in
accordance with the flood risk
assessment which recommends permeable
materials
excellent thank you very much thank you
both uh council adam next please
thank you um it was hopefully a
reasonably easy one
when looking at overshadowing effects
obviously the neighbor
uh who spoke had concerns with his
conservatory
um and conservatories are somewhat
different from other parts of the house
and that they
they benefit from light through the roof
is there
a different standard as it were in in
the way we assess overshadowing for
conservatories for other parts of
neighboring properties
yeah so when we're looking at the at
conservatories obviously they can get
light from all sides
um and as far as i recall and i'm aware
there are no
sort of numerical guidelines set out in
the development requirements spd
with regards separation distances to
conservatories
but this one in particular you know it's
a case-by-case assessment
this one i have assessed as it will lose
some light um to the direct side
but it still has the roof the front and
the rear from which to gain light
and so i don't consider it to be
detrimentally affected
thank you that's useful okay um remember
this last couple of seconds before we
move to debate if you've got any
questions for sarah please ask them now
no one indicating okay let's move to
debate who would like to kick us oh just
as i was about to say it councillor
mills has a question for you sarah
casper mills come in
sarah i can just see on the um
on this uh plan
sokoway is that already there the soak
away or is that planned
is that is that going to be there
sorry so do the the on the plan here
i can see soak away is that already
there
or is it going to be installed once
these houses are built
i can't see what you're seeing so you'll
have to indicate is this the proposed
site plan or the existing perhaps that
you're
the the proposed site plan it's got
i can just see a little circle with
soakaway on it
give me a moment uh
yep that is proposed as far as i'm aware
it doesn't appear to be
on the exit that's all i want to know
thank you very much so mr chairman thank
you
that's quite all right council mills
thank you let's move into the debate
then who would like to kick us off
and if i don't hear from anyone i'm
going to pick on councillor mills for
beating me to it last council parry's
beating you to it so you're all right
councillor parry please
save the day for councillor mills um
i totally understand the concerns um
of of of the parish council um
and i and i understand the concerns of
of the neighbor but unfortunately
um from a planning material point of
view
views um don't come into it looking at
this
um we haven't got an objection from the
environmental
uh for them from the environment agency
um whilst whilst i can understand
local residents don't like it the parish
council doesn't like it
um i can't see i haven't got a planning
reason in front of me
to refuse this so um my sympathies to
them but i'm gonna have to go with the
officer's recommendation
thank you check council power is that a
formal proposal
yeah thank you very much councillor
mills
thanks mr chairman yes um my concern is
is
about the flooding and and the fact that
they're going to put a soak away in
there
they they're obviously um worried about
flooding
themselves um as council fleming said
you know
the um there's no respect to water i
mean they got
blood seven three conveniently stops
where the um
uh the new proposed development is so
i'm really worried about that mr
chairman um
it's happening kinda it just
it has no respect so i'm at the moment
i'm going to go against the officer's
recommendation purely on flooding
it's difficult thank you
thank you very much cancer mills
councillor kendall please
thank you chairman um i would probably
echo exactly what councilor parry has
said while i
really sympathize with the neighbours
and with the parish council i can
completely understand where they're
coming from
you look at the the the possible
problems with this i i'm not seeing any
planning grahams really i think
the overlooking issue is going to be
obscured glass unless i misheard that
the flood we don't have a an objection
regarding
flooding it's it's i hate to say if it
feels like unsubstantiated fears of
flooding
which is uh which is considerable given
the weather tonight
but as i say i can't find any um any
planning grounds to go again
so i'm happy to second uh capsule harry
bye bliss thank you very much cancer
kendall uh for what it's worth um i am
in the same boat as you both i'm
struggling to find any planning reasons
to go against um and will therefore be
supporting
um councillor jennings has indicated his
wish to speak to council jennings before
we go to a vote
yeah sorry
i pretty much agree with everything
which has been said so far i mean with
with things like street views i mean
with the new government white paper you
can add an extra floor onto a
onto a bungalow anyhow with under
permissive development
so you know what used to be there
what you used what you used to get with
views is all going to change um
but yeah i said i
don't like it particularly but um
i can't i haven't got a material
planning reason to go against the
officer's uh decision on this
okay and no one else has indicated the
desire to speak we have a proposal it
has been seconded let's move to a vote
uh
i will go first the proposal is to grant
in line with the offers recommendation
councilor richards four thank you
chairman councillor kendall
councillor kendall four councillor adam
paul councillor cramp caster crump for
council councils councillor curtis
taking into account the objections of
the parish and others
abstain thank you councillor dixon
councillor dixon for councillor jennings
counselor jennings for council mills
council mills against and councillor
parry
councillor perry
that's 7 4 chairman one abstention and
one against
thank you very much and that goes
committee resolves to grant application
twenty zero
two four four six ful at fifteen canal
close in bedford
on avon okay um we are now
moving very quickly towards half past
eight which as everyone knows
uh is the final cut off for starting our
uh last item for the evening we do still
have three items left so
um the item we're about to hear will be
our last this evening
um apologies to uh both our officers
and those who have registered to speak
and the applicants for the final
two if you are in any way connected to
registered speak
on uh or here to listen uh about
uh either application twenty zero one
six
one two very that's a hundred high
street in biddeford
or twenty zero two six one two ful
that's green end farm in ships
and scour both of those will be deferred
until our next planning committee
meeting and they will be the first
two items to be heard at that planning
committee meeting
again my apologies for that could i ask
our committee services
officers to advise the uh the speakers
on both those last
two items i'll be very grateful
okay let's move into what is now our
final item for the evening application
reference twenty zero
one three nine eight ful that's filled
adjacent to glenn has farmed henley road
in clarendon
once again sarah mcpherson is our
presenting officer sarah
before you start actually i can hear
myself getting some feedback so
for members of the public that have
registered to speak on this final app
on this application if you could please
mute your phones your handsets by
pressing
star and six that's the asterisks uh
number six
um and if you can turn off any live
streams in the background
uh they are slightly delayed um so
you're better off following on
the handset rather than the live stream
the feedback has stopped which is good
so sarah apologies again
i can see the uh the red line graph on
the screen so whenever you're ready do
start
perfect thank you chair this application
is for the erection of an agricultural
barn
at field adjacent to glenhurst farm the
site is identified here by the red line
a bridal wave runs adjacent to the site
and some distance to the east is the
listed crown inn
indicated in red
the site is identified here by a black
dot
and here an ariel illustrates where we
are in relation to clavidin
the location plan in the corner shows
that the applicant owns the whole field
edged blue
but only a small part of it is included
within the red line for this application
this proposed site plan illustrates the
key features
the existing access will not be altered
a corner of hedge will be removed in
order to better reflect the land
ownership
the bomb will be cited in the upper
right corner and there will be a hedge
planted to screen it
which replaces a similar hedge
previously removed
here are the elevations of the barn a
floor plan and a roof plan
you can see that the barn is small as
they come with an area for storage of
machinery a place for storage of hay
bales
under general maintenance and working
area
these photos show the site access which
is to be unchanged
as well as a view across the site
towards the location of the barn
indicated with the red arrow
that's the end of my presentation and i
draw your attention
to two updates on the update sheet thank
you
sarah thank you very much for that let's
move straight to our first
speaker which uh who is counselor simon
lawton the chairman of cleveland parish
council
council lawton welcome can you hear me
please press star and six if you're
still muted
councillor lawton hopefully you can hear
me start and sex will unmute your
handset
counselor lorton could i have
confirmation from our
committee services that council order is
or the parish council have been able to
uh to phone in this evening
fortunately i do have a copy of
councillor lawton's propose i think i do
anyway
go with me while i pull that up onto my
screen and i will read it out
to you forgive me hopefully you can all
still hear me
um forgive me if i get this slightly
muddled it's the first time i've read it
and it's coming from a jpg
file so it's a little difficult to read
uh but council lawton would like to say
the following
clavidon parish council's objection to
glenn hurst farm application
in our two-page objection to this
application sadly not issued with
tonight's gen agenda
councillors will note that cleveland pc
are very dubious in regards
to the motives for the application our
own expert appraisal by a former nfu
economics director and current director
of the agriculture and horticultural
development board
clearly disproves the findings of
planned department specialities
sorry specialists these are as follows
planning regulations allow permitted
development for farm buildings up to 400
square meters
where the land is greater than five
hectares this land parcel is somewhere
below the threshold
it's less than three hectares hence the
need for planning permission
the parish council is concerned that the
proposed agriculture enterprise does not
generate the economic output to sustain
a farm building of this size
and is therefore not appropriate the
average turnover of
the farm business of sorry off-farm
businesses in the west midlands
is 1 908 pounds per hectare
generating a profit of 63 pounds per
hectare
on this site that means a profit of less
than 200 pounds is expected to sustain
the investment in this facility and the
wider farming enterprise that it that is
proposed
as a result the pc believes the site
will in due course switch to industrial
or residential use
in addition there are outstanding
enforcement issues on this site
following the removal of hundreds of
meters of ancient hedgerows
in contravention of the hedera's
regulations 1997.
in any consent for the application cloud
and pc would wish that any existing
permitted development rights under
national and district planning policies
are excluded
to ensure that the building is preserved
for agricultural storage in perpetuity
and not for any other use cleveland
parish council would also ask that the
current enforcement action is
in respect of the destruction of ancient
hedgerows be vigorously enacted
in the event that this application is
refused with the applicant being
required to complete
full reinstatement we could
as to whether the applicant who has
already angered many local residents by
his actions on both parcels of his
recently acquired land
has any experience in agriculture in
agriculture
but that but that is not a planning
issue
we would hope that the enforcement
officers continue to put rightly
unlawful destruction of heteros
our planning consultants have confirmed
that this is perfectly acceptable
to condition in any planning content
consent to exclude any committed
development rights in respect of future
residential and industrial use of the
site or building
if cancers are minded to grant consent
it should be subject
to this conditioning and that concludes
the uh representation made by uh
councillor lawton
on behalf of the parish council i'm
afraid clearly i can't ask
answer any questions uh so we will move
to our next speaker if council lawn is
able to
dial in shortly then we will ask him to
answer questions otherwise we will move
to our
is that you there yes it is yeah you are
you sound a million miles away at the
moment um
you may have hurt i'm in cleveland we're
a million miles away
um so you you may have heard that i um i
have a copy of your
chairman chairman i didn't hear anything
okay so i don't know why but i i've been
listening to this
ghastly uh two to our meeting and
and couldn't well i've been on it all
day
okay okay so uh castle you are live now
um and we can hear you i have read your
uh
full representation uh verbatim uh if
you'd like to
i have um if you'd like to just hold on
and i'll see if any of our members have
any questions for you
so members could you integrate the truth
okay can i can i just say
we've been here for um you know two and
a half hours now and i've been on this
committee before
and hopefully you could hear me um this
is a very simple
um application um
club and parish council have now heard
the um what you've written or what i've
written
um i mean basically um this is a house
and oh i'm not hearing you
you we we can still hear you counselor
lorton okay
plea please bear in mind though that we
have had your representation so please
keep whatever you've got to say
to uh uh keep it limited if you would
please
oh well i i will i was going to keep it
in 30 seconds
okay i'm assuming you you've said what
you need to say so we're going to move
to questions now if i may councillor
mills has indicated
thank you castle mills has indicated his
desire to answer your questions are
councillor mills please fire away
hi simon uh good to hear from you simon
um
i i always usually ask this sort of
question
was there consultation uh between the
applicants and the parish council
any consultation on that none whatsoever
councillor mills
thank you councillor simon
okay um i don't see any further uh
counselors wishing to ask a question um
in fact i'm seeing lots of shaking heads
so
cancel thank you for joining us
as i have not had um chances
counsel and i think we might have lost
you again can you confirm you can still
hear me
okay i think we've lost councillor
lawton sadly um
uh there i must admit there is very
limited uh
uh mobile phone signal in claverden um
so it sound
it seems like we've lost him through
that let's move on shall we
um we move to our uh final speaker for
the evening in fact uh mr
chima who is the applicant mr chima can
you hear me okay
marvel's fabulous first time so you've
got three minutes and we'll give you a
30-second warning whenever you're ready
do feel free to start
thank you thanks uh i'd just like to
highlight five areas in support of the
application and to counter objections
firstly the yield the yield is not over
inflated it's been calculated
by what was acquired in summer 2020 by a
local farmer
mark smith and has been verified by
photographic evidence as provided in the
application secondly finance the motive
for this project is not finance there
are no financial aims
i don't want to get into my personal
affairs but there is no need for me to
make
any profit out of this i've already
spent several thousand pounds
on improving the soil fencing entrance
of the land and
irrigation and take offense of the comet
that this is just a house i've also
supported local farmers to farmers now
to use this land at no charge to support
them through difficult financial times
i embark on this proposal with
sufficient financing place to ensure
that the project attempts to achieve two
key aims number one returning the land
to full
agricultural use and number two promote
a well-being project
for myself and my family by engaging in
small-scale farming in the area around
the barn
in stage eight of a five-year plan and
is detailed in the five-year plan
using part of the land to extend this
well-being project to members of the
local community
including the local school as i did with
my land at breach lane
the hedgerow i've been offering to
restore the hedgerow which was removed
without my knowledge since march 2019
and there has been evidence in emails
presented as part of the application but
i've been asked to await permission
from stratfor district council officer
wayne bellamy i've even suggested types
of hedges to plant
this was what rejected there's been no
information for coming from mr bellamy
so has been included as part of this
application to restore the hedgerow i've
emailed evidence of this
correspondence glennus farm the
objection that the location of the barn
would compromise
into the residence of glenhurst farm has
been overcome in the planning
application
but in addition to this i would be
willing to um
screen the primitive of the land the
borders their land
adjacent to the property with a hedgerow
for increased privacy
and finally local in terms of local
community
i'm very keen to become more involved
with the local community not only am i
currently looking to purchase a
residential property
within the local area but take a look at
my actions at the land off breach lane
where i have offered to donate this land
to the local primary school and even
drew up plans at a cost of several
thousand pounds
to develop a learning and local
community side unfortunately this was
rejected by the head teacher after plans
have been drawn up
these four and a half acres have been
taken into account have
taken from an inaccessible piece of land
to where we now the fully cleared and
secured entrance improved access
fencing reinforcer replaced a water
supply installed
the soil improved and access given to
the primary school
this land will be in this application we
manage in the same commitment and
respect for the local area
thank you mr shima thank you very much
for that members do you have any
questions
for our applicant please please indicate
in the chat if you do i'm seeing a lot
of shaking heads
nope okay mr thank you very much for
your contribution this evening you're
best off
hanging up your handset and continuing
to watch on the live stream
but thank you again thanks okay
members do we have any questions or
points for clarification of our officer
councillor jennings is in first please
thank you chairman um it's been raised
by the parish
council objection that concerns over
future conversion under class
q i understood that if it has to have
been built prior to
2013 to have for that to come into place
so i'm presuming that that isn't a that
isn't a factor
if you just clarify that please that's
just one question i've got one more
afterwards if
you don't okay yeah
of course so obviously the conversion to
a class q um
is a possibility for an agricultural
barn generally speaking
um it is the government's intention that
they have that permit development right
um development is not permitted by class
q
if the site was not solely used for
agricultural use
as part of an agricultural unit um in
march 2013
or if it was in use before that date
when it was last in use
or if it was brought most relevant to
this if it was bought into use
after 2013 for a period of at least 10
years
so it's quite complexly worded and
so development is not permitted if the
site was not used for agriculture
for a period of at least 10 years which
they don't make it easy to understand do
they um but
to answer your question essentially it
would be subject to the same rules and
regulations as any other agricultural
barn
if it were to go full class q in the
future
um but to my mind what could potentially
happen to it in the future is not a
reason
to restrict the granting of plan
permission um for this application
that would be sort of you know reaching
a little bit i'm saying
okay so my other question was um
yields of hay um and whether
the the viability of the agricultural
venture
i'm presuming that's not a material
planning matter
and well we have consulted kernan's
agricultural consultants
on this application and and we basically
asked them
is the size of the building the sighting
of it and the use and things is it
suitable for
the the agricultural enterprise that
they propose
and after some amendments they have said
yes
and part of the assessment isn't whether
or not it would be a viable agricultural
enterprise that sort of
it you know it's up to the applicant
what they want to do with their land it
was it was more just whether
the building was suitable for what they
wanted to do not whether that would be a
profit-making enterprise because that is
not relevant
great thank you very much thank you very
much both of you counselor adam next
please thanks and um hopefully an easy
one
um yes you've noticed that kernan's um
provided
uh a sort of viability assessment as it
were um the
parish councillor suggested that um they
consulted somebody from the nfu
um who um maybe contradicted that have
you received any
evidence to that effect
let me just check my file
i think it is detailed within the parish
council response
that they have sought advice and
i think some of their advice was based
on their their own experience
as counselors um and i think they did
also mention that they sought
independent advice
but i haven't actually seen you know the
letter from
whoever they sought advice from or
anything like that it's just been
relayed that they have done so
sure okay thank you for that appreciate
it
lovely and account a question from
councillor dixon as well please
thank you chairman sarah um there were
obviously questions about viability
um i think you can possibly clarify in
my own mind when kernens do
make a an assessment we often call on
them
when an assessment is being made for the
provision of an
agricultural residential property for a
farmer to live in
and then kernels are required to show
that the farm is viable to support
the occupation is that where viability
comes in as opposed to the current
situation
um i haven't actually dealt with an
application for an agricultural workers
dwelling
quite some time so i can't recall
precisely what we consult
kernan's on but i do have their response
in front of me
and so i can confirm what they did
consider and that was whether the use of
the building is appropriate
whether the size is appropriate for its
intended use if it's suitable design for
the intended use
if the sighting is appropriate and
whether there are any other buildings
which would be suitable to meet the
needs of the enterprise
so an assessment of viability was not
carried out
and we would not require it to be
carried out because viability isn't a
requirement
of having an agricultural building
thank you sarah lovely okay
um i see no one else indicating they
wish to ask any points for clarification
so oh i'll ask one quickly if i may
actually say um
would it be appropriate as the parish
council suggested to remove all
permitted development rights
going forward
um i think i would potentially want to
discuss this
with um with the planning manager tracy
potentially
um with a word with our legal advisor as
well
and to my mind it potentially wouldn't
be because it's the
government's intention that farm
buildings have that right
um you know after a certain period of
time our legal advice
has um clarified for me that to apply
for a class q it must have been in
agricultural use for 10 years
which um i should hope gives a certain
degree of reassurance and that this
would be a genuine application for
agricultural use
um but obviously if members did want to
pursue removing that pd right then i
think
it might be wise for us to have a bit of
a discussion with them
with tracy and perhaps ross as well okay
well let's let's cross that bridge when
we come to it i think rather than
getting too far into it now
um there being no further questions for
clarification let's
uh open up debate who would like to
start us off with that
i might pick on councillor mills oh
councillor jennings has got
who's got their first council jennings
yeah thank you chairman
and i know that we're here to guess
what's going to happen to this property
in the future
and we're just going to go on on what we
have in front of us
um i think this is fairly simple oh i
don't know
i've absolutely no reason to go again
see no material planning reason to go
against the officer's recommendation
to grant this application or therefore
like to propose to regret this
application
okay thank you very much councilman
mills next please
thank you chairman i i think they've
already been said
yeah um the fact that it can't be
uh turned into residential use for 10
years i think this is quite a genuine
application let's say we don't know what
could happen in 10 years times i'm
quite happy to support the officer's
recommendation mr chairman thank you
lovely thank you very much um a series
of people have indicated their desire to
second
um councillor dixon was the first to do
that council dixon do you want to speak
to that please
no chairman i'm perfectly happy simply
to second lovely thank you
um okay tracy ross um coming back to the
permitted development clearly we've had
that question posed from the parish
council
um my gut fear is that we would need to
have a pretty strong reason
uh to support our decision to remove any
permitted development right
could you give us an indication as to
whether i'm correct with that
uh shall i go first chairman yes thank
you for further question
um i think sarah answered the question
very well
in fairness um class q um
has a whole series of criteria which
would have to be applicable for a class
q
um conversion to be undertaken one of
which is the length of time it's already
been in agricultural use
um ross has during the debate had a
quick look at the matter and confirmed
that it would need to be in agricultural
use for 10 years
so we don't feel that it would be
appropriate or indeed necessary at this
stage to withdraw permitted development
rights for that accepting that if the
applicant were to put in
a class queue notification
that we would then fully assess it in
relation to all the caveats which are
set out in that section of the gpdo
which are many and varied so i think in
summary um and
ross may wish to comment afterwards uh
officers will conclude that we
don't need to withdraw permitted
development rights
in this instance i agree with that
i'd agree tracy that understood
and clears the position up as far as i'm
concerned beautifully um cancer adam i
see you indicated your desire to second
as well do you want to speak to that or
are you happy for me to move to a vote
oh please move on chairman thank you
that's said with such great enthusiasm
um okay in that case we have a proposal
to grant
application twenty zero one three nine
eight full uh that's his field adjacent
to glenhurst farm in clavedon
uh the proposal is to grant in line with
the office of recommendation
i will go first councillor richards four
thank you chairman councillor fleming
caster flowing for
councillor curtis councillor curtis for
councillor dixon councillor dixon for
councillor jennings councillor jennings
fall
captain mills council mills for
a councillor parry councillor perry four
that's unanimous chairman thank you very
much liz
um in that case committee resolves to
grant application twenty zero one
three nine eight ful phil adjacent to
glendale's farm in clavidon
okay um we have obviously already
deferred our final two items in line
with our constitution they will be the
first to heard at our next meeting in
two weeks
time there being no uh urgent business i
can therefore
thank everyone for their contributions
this evening particularly our officers
our public and our speaker and our of
course our members
and those behind the scenes making sure
this runs smoothly or as smooth as it
can
thank you everyone i declare the meeting
closed